major news breaking uh just earlier
today the FDA has announced that they're
going to be restricting the J J vaccine
for only certain uh individuals have to
be over 18 and you otherwise cannot
receive other vaccines so we'll get into
this this is because of the
um blood clot risk now there's something
really funny that's happening in this
story which we can focus quite a bit on
and that's Twitter is using old fact
checks to restrict this breaking news
which is dangerous because if I mean
this news is coming out the FDA has
issued a new guideline and if they are
restricting that news people could get
hurt that is the problem with censorship
so we'll talk about that but my friends
there's also Pfizer data which came out
now
I hate to say it but I'm fairly
confident that if we actually showed the
data on what the Pfizer dump was we
would get banned instantly I'm not even
exaggerating it's that insane so what
we'll do is we're going to save that for
the website segment which comes up after
the show and um with apologies I suppose
because I don't know how else we'd be
able to actually have these
conversations because we're actually
going to be showing breaking 9-1-1 on
Twitter is getting restricted censored
for showing what is literally true from
the FDA because these systems are
completely broken which brings me to a
big announcement first let me just say
Elon Musk is expected to be the new CEO
of Twitter at least temporarily which is
huge he's brought in more investors
we'll talk about that timcast is now
officially operating on Rumble
infrastructure timcast.com it is now
faster stronger and better more
resilient against censorship and it's
just the first move we're making in
supporting and implementing new
infrastructure to to make ourselves more
resistant to censorship but also support
systems that are this is going to put
Market competition and all these other
services like like Amazon and Google so
it's one step it's good one of the one
of the concerns we definitely had in the
past was even though we were doing
member segments on our on on our own
website at timcast.com we could still be
censored they could come and say oh we
don't want to host these things well
we're making these changes there's a
there's a lot of news to go through in
terms of censorship PayPal is currently
Under Fire for censoring a bunch of
Independent News so we'll talk about all
of that plus we've got news
about this teacher who was fired for
violating the parental rights and
education bill so um needless to say I
think today is going to be really really
interesting and um this J J stuff is
particularly fascinating joining us
tonight to talk about all of this is
Ashley Sinclair hello do you want to
introduce yourself yes I am an author of
elephants are not Birds which is a book
to combat a lot of the liberal
transgender antidotes going on now um
and I am now the senior culture
contributor at the post millennial so
check out that stuff with a whole crew
of people at thepostmillennial.com right
on I'm Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons
called Freedom Tunes we just uploaded
one today on the left leaving Twitter
and the fact that they need an alternate
platform now if they invented one what
would it be like I think you guys will
enjoy that cartoon also I am thrilled to
hear that we cannot say what the science
is now telling us because that would be
anti-science because it's Twitter
I want to know more uh hey I'm glad
we're working with Rumble too man we've
been working in the back uh behind the
scenes with decentralizing servers and
Chris at Rumble Chris pavlovsky's been
fantastic to work with their crew is
amazing I'm really happy to to be
involved in this uh upgrade of the
internet and going heading towards web
3.0 and Beyond I asked you before the
show Ashley about your last name
Sinclair if there was a Saint Claire
turns out there is Claire of Assisi I
didn't know much about her but she was a
uh an Italian Saint and one of the first
followers of Francis of Assisi that's
that's really cool there's a Saint
Timothy as well yeah
um who has got to be the center of it
[Laughter]
which one is the is the is it Saint
Timothy who's the the one of
gastrointestinal I think that is we
talked about this a little while ago
yeah I believe so I can double check I
don't want to spread misinformation and
I've noticed since I've been working
with you gastrointestinal man the better
I feel in my gut the better I feel in my
mind well I often is it is it that's who
it is uh Saint Timothy is the patron
saint of stomach and intestinal ailments
yeah that's right that's him and I've
often heard that my soothing voice cures
people's diarrhea
Yeah Tim I think like that's spreading
scientific
advertising yeah yeah all right we got
Lydia my voice does not cure people's
diary I'm very sorry but I'm very
excited to have Ashley on this evening
we're having a lot of fun talking over
the show and I think it's gonna be a lot
of fun yes my friends but before we get
started you must head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com to get your
virtual private Network virtual Shield
you'll get 50 off a virtual private
Network gives you a basic layer of
security as you browse the web to
protect your from hackers spies
governments corporations they want to
siphon off your data virtual Shield is
an excellent way to protect yourself as
you browse the web and an additional
shout out because virtual showed us our
first sponsor so in these trying times
cancel culture in the culture War you
definitely want to be supporting
companies that are getting behind the
work we do and are fearless in that
sponsorship their VPN service is
compatible with all devices allowing you
to browse the web safely secure securely
and anonymously lets you browse the web
so that big name internet service
providers and other third parties will
not be able to Monitor and sell your
internet activity and browsing history
while using their VPN your traffic is
routed through secure and encrypted
servers so any restrictions censorship
or blocks on your internet are bypassed
completely free for 30 days it's on it
works for Mac Windows iPhone iPad
Android and Chrome
virtual Shield does all the work it even
encrypts your Wi-Fi signal there's
personal family and business plans
available family includes 15 devices
business plan all allows you to add as
many employees as you need virtual
Shield as I mentioned will encrypt your
Wi-Fi so guys
surfinginternetsafe.com 50 off lifetime
discount and again shout out to Virtual
shield for being our first sponsor and
sticking through all of these years
despite all of these smears and all that
castle culture stuff but don't forget
head over to timcast.com become a member
because uh as much as you know I hate to
say it
the world we live in is dreadfully
censorious the reason why this Elon Musk
knows is so good is because we may be
taking back some ground in our ability
to communicate but uh there is a story
coming out right now many people believe
that the Roe v Wade leak was to cover
for the Pfizer data release well our
journalists started looking at the
Pfizer data and the News That's Coming
Out is so shocking I am extremely
confident that if I said even one data
point from this data we would be banned
instantly so how about we'll talk about
the fda's new announcement on the J J
vaccine and the censorship around that
and then we'll go to timcast.com for the
news that they um they're not going to
let us talk about it's unfortunate but
uh we can still do it on timcast.com and
what I refer to as our little speakeas
of the members only segment and we also
do have the Articles up so if you're not
happy with the way YouTube runs things
don't worry we have more infrastructure
stuff happening as we move forward we
can't do it all at once but I mentioned
we are officially on rumbles
infrastructure for our website so they
can't take these articles down one step
at a time we're working as hard and as
fast as we can as a member you're making
all that possible so don't forget smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and let's take a look at this major
update from the FDA today we limited the
authorized use of the Jansen covid-19
vaccine to those 18 and over for whom
other authorized approved vaccines are
not accessible or clinically appropriate
and to those who elect Jansen because
they would otherwise not receive a
coveted vaccine so that last part's
particularly interesting
but the news
is that it's over the blood clot clot
risk you uh U.S restricts use of Johnson
and Johnson coveted vaccine over rare
blood clot risk the FDA said the shot
should be given only to those who
request it or cannot receive other
vaccines and you have to be 18 and older
my understanding is that the data on
this is not I don't I don't think it's
new that we've known about the risk of
blood cuts for some time it was actually
taken off the market for some time
so I'm wondering if I suppose my issue
initially that we can we can jump into
here
how many people should have gotten this
FDA warning some time ago if we knew
about the blood clot risk yeah I mean
well if this is something we knew about
everyone should have been able to know
they should have been able to make an
informed decision about what they were
putting in their body and the risk it
posed to them because this information
was kept from us because we couldn't
really accelerate the dialogue around
the vaccines in order to get the best
information about it because anyone who
contradicted The Narrative was told that
they were not trusting the science
there are serious consequences yeah this
we're talking about human lives here
right it's in a society in an ideal
Society immediately everyone should know
if there's a problem like this but in
hyper sensitive sensorious areas you
can't that's the big problem with with
censorship like not censorship in
general but just like Mis
misappropriated censorship or over over
censor what are you gonna so I was gonna
say they The Establishment likes to do
this retroactive fact-checking thing
where let's say uh today a man uh
gets in a rocket ship and flies off and
he screams I'm going to the moon and
we're like oh wow that was crazy and
then we come on the show and we say did
you hear the story about that guy who
got the rocket ship and yelled he was
going to the Moon that crazy
a week later the news comes out he
actually went to Mars and what they'll
do is they'll say fact check false will
get flagged and the right story saying
they spread disinformation about the man
in the rocket ship who's actually going
to Mars so what happens is we can come
out and talk about lab leak for instance
in covid and we'll say based on the
current contextual information our best
assessment is this
a week later the news changes the fact
Checkers then take your old story and
call you fake news based on information
that came out a week later you see the
games let me let me let me show you
that's not what happens to fauci though
ever oh right right no but they hit a
lot of this information too we knew we
knew about the blood clots we knew about
especially with women they were having
issues with their menstrual cycles and
they covered it up and all the headlines
were it doesn't affect your period it
doesn't affect your menstrual cycle the
blood clots are for the first few months
that was the story and then a few months
later they're like oh by the way women
are reporting issues with their
menstrual cycles take a look at this
from breaking 9-1-1 they say strange how
the ap's Tweet same exact headline isn't
flagged as misleading the AP said U.S
Regulators strictly limited who can
receive J's Copa 19 vaccine due to a
rare but serious risk of blood clots the
FDA said the shot should only be given
to adults okay so we we know that take a
look at this photo
breaking 9-1-1 posting an image breaking
FDA restricts J J covid-19 vaccine due
to blood clot risk misleading learn why
Health officials consider covid-19
vaccines safe for most people here's the
best part that misleading tag linked to
an April first fact check
so old information fact checking a new
breaking story and it could have been an
April Fool's joke for all we know that's
right how are we supposed to know for
sure well right now if you look at
breaking 9-1-1 they've they've they've
actually removed the misleading uh flag
on it but they do give breaking 9-1-1
according to newsguard a not they give
it a fake news here's here's where it
gets even better the headline used by
breaking 9-1-1 is identical to the New
York Post now I know they said the same
as the AP the ap's headline was
different it says serious but rare
theirs doesn't but the New York Post is
identical
that's the problem with censorship so
now we have
we have the story coming out from Pfizer
this big data dump and it's actually
quite alarming and the problem is the
people working at YouTube right now the
sensors many of them are probably not
even in the US
they have no idea so even nisk even this
story right now breaking the FDA has
strictly restricted the J the JJ vaccine
we run the risk of getting banned
because YouTube sensors are looking at a
little they got like a laminated placard
it says when to ban someone they're like
if they talk bad about vaccines you got
to ban them uh well they are yes
probably more specific they have a slack
Channel where they send it out this
article and they're like is this
bannable they're like well no that's got
this but if you know and then they they
cross-reference it with like if they do
it in this context yeah if it's in this
context no no no no no no and then they
have to make individuals these are
outsourced um these are outsourced the
people who are doing the Banning many of
them aren't in this country or not on
slack channels and I think the fact that
we're looking at Twitter this is why I'm
making the point Twitter censored uh
breaking911 due to month old information
it's a new story that goes to show you
the people who are flagging it are not
communicating on what this news is but
they're not doing it for peanuts either
it's always in the best interest of
these bigwigs like the hunter Biden
story that was the most egregious of all
but the hunter Biden story they're
protecting big Pharma it's all of these
things it's not peanuts that they're
going after but that's why we need the
open source algorithm that's why it's so
important and what elon's doing is
incredible I will I will say to Ian's
Point freeing the code the one thing
that we absolutely need to do is free
the algorithm the recommendation all of
that stuff needs to be open source I
don't think these companies should be
allowed to hide that because what do
they do behind the scenes they lie to
Congress about censorship manipulation
there was a really great question from a
Republican
I can't remember who they asked they
said why is it that when you sign up for
Twitter you are shown nothing but
Democrats to follow really yep if you
were in Washington DC and you and you
sign up for Twitter on a brand new
computer it gives you all Democrats and
they were like that must be an oversight
on our part free the code until last
Tuesday yeah exactly release the code
and let us know if you're lying or not
because it's one thing you know we have
this discussion the other night about
whether all of the code should be
released well the infrastructure that
holds the building up I disagree with
Ian on but in terms of how they're
manipulating what we see and what we
think you shouldn't be allowed to do a
lot of people message me about security
through obfuscation which is part of
keeping your security code private and
they said that's been completely
obliterated and is useless you need to
open source the security code too so it
can be poked and prodded and then
resolved and made stronger but when you
say free the code you got to be specific
you need to make these things become
interoperable and I agree that you need
algorithm I'm just I'm saying
specifically for now where I would agree
on releasing the code to the public is
Elon Musk says he when he gets to
Twitter he wants to make the algorithm
open source and he should that way
everybody knows that they're not
manipulating politics I think they're
already doing cleanup though I don't
think they want us to know and we saw
that the unthrottling of so many
accounts I was like wow all of a sudden
I have all these things I gained like
200 000 followers in a few days it's
crazy I had been you know stagn you know
I was still gaining but it was stagnant
for the most part and then all of a
sudden it was like the floodgates open
up for so many people but I think
they're they're doing cleanup and how
fast they removed that warning shows it
too that they're they're a little more
cognizant well I tweeted to Elon I said
hey yo Elon Musk check this an old fact
check has restricted a new story about
the vaccine it got a thousand retweets I
think I'm not saying it was me I'm
saying a bunch of people were tweeting
out like crazy yeah for sure what's
going on yeah you contributed for sure
you contributed to that one problem with
open sourcing the algorithm here and
seeing is that it doesn't stop an errant
administrator from censoring something
in India if they're working remote and
they they like are like no we're gonna
we're gonna downvote that you'll you may
be able to track that it happened but
you still don't know who did it and why
they did it that's all like business
talk now you're saying do we have to
open up their slack channels so we can
watch them communicate and that's like
basically the beginning of the end of
the corporation if you're gonna but is
that also Justified let's let's talk
about that man when it I'd be willing to
bet a large sum of money that if you
took Twitter's internal slack channels
which is their internal communication
between employees assuming it's slack or
some other yeah whatever whatever
they're using yeah I don't want to drag
slack Slack's a great company but um if
they're using some kind of messaging
service and you got to see the full
archive there's going to be tons of
people saying can we ban the
conservatives how do we get these people
off the channels and we know this it's
not opinion because project Veritas has
already released videos where you have
employees these big tech companies
saying we try to get them banned we try
to get them removed that was Media
Matters there was Media Matters who was
bragging about getting project Veritas
and James O'Keefe ripped off that
reference I was giving was actually I
think an employee from one of these
companies really saying that inside the
company we are trying to get them banned
but yes but then they also got Media
Matters bragging about getting and I
tweeted it out for them I had never been
mentioned by Media Matters that I know
of and I tweeted it out and I was making
fun of that whoever was in the video all
of a sudden I was mentioned in a Media
Matters article for nothing for my for
my children's book after I made fun of
them
yeah Media Matters is an interesting
organization we've had a couple
conversations about them and it's funny
because you two are going back and forth
about these different examples of the
left basically being caught trying to
suppress right-wing content even though
they claim that's something that isn't
really happening isn't it interesting
how the stories that conservatives
promote about how our side is being
maligned or unfairly treated are
actually true in literally every single
instance of the left upholding its
persecution narrative with the story of
some kind of hate crime is completely
nonsensical and turns out to be untrue
when you look into it just a little bit
I just want to shout out that Gizmodo
article it's the best example of this
Facebook former Facebook workers
routinely suppressed conservative news
outlets this is what kicked off the
whole story about censorship and I see
that and it's 2016. I think I'm working
for Fusion at the time and I was like
hey look at this news that I know and
trust wow they were censoring
conservatives
I say that it's happening and I get
called a liar or right-wing for saying
it Facebook's weird though because then
they were giving a lot of money to
targeted Victory right and that was a
republican group to make things against
Tick Tock as a competitor so they're
weird they'll do things like that but
then they'll but they'll now they give
money to conservatives and so they're
still censoring them but it's just such
a weird relationship because Facebook I
feel like is different because they just
do whatever for the money whereas I feel
like Twitter is a little more beholden
to the Mob
um but you're seeing me how fast they
clean this up it took them how long for
the hunter Biden story and this this
this disclaimer's gone within what a day
I think it's really fascinating didn't
fauci say we're out of the pandemic or
something like that
she still existed well maybe you should
pay attention to the fact she thought he
banned it I thought he vanished would
you go to www.fouchie.com you can't get
into another pandemic until you get out
of the old one now I got the chicken
thing happening I think we need another
one Bill Gates was like when we get into
the next pandemic he's getting everybody
fearful about the next one he's like
we're releasing an update
there's the the chicken flu now that
they're freaking out about but what so
do you brought up isn't that already a
thing bird flu no but it's like jumped
the new one jump to a person I didn't I
kind of felt like I derailed your
comment about fauci was there something
you were gonna yeah that he said
something about we're out of the
pandemic already I I saw something like
that and I'm just wondering you know
myth-informed posted that clip of The
Joe Rogan podcast where I asked Vegeta
would they ban someone for vaccine
misinformation and she says no it's not
against our policies and uh you know
sure if they went did it so their
policies changed because the pandemic
happened now the pandemic's over is
there the same level of risk yeah this
from washingtonpost.com if fauci says
U.S is out of coronavirus quote pandemic
phase well there you come fauci that's
from the science and I say that as a
joke he is not the science so does
Twitter now give up its emergency powers
and stops Banning people for these
things because it's no longer a greater
risk no I mean when does when does any
organization government or otherwise
take power from the public because of
some kind of emergency and then give it
back once the emergency is over I mean
uh-oh what's this WebMD says fauci
clarifies out of the pandemic phase uh
oh he said Wayne I need another time
cover what what what what are they
saying here he said we don't have 900
000 new infections a day we are at a low
level now so if you're asking are we out
of the pandemic phase we are
okay so all right pandemic phase is over
all right so do we all move on is that
it or yeah well it's over till they
don't want it to be over anymore this is
part of what's so frustrating about this
entire thing they can flip the narrative
in a second and then they say oh the
science changes and that would be all
well and good if they were allowing any
dissident who tried to provide the
public data that didn't support their
Narrative of voice right but they
silence everybody and if the science is
always changing then that's all the more
reason to allow people to speak out when
they have a perspective that conflicts
with the current narrative because the
current narrative could always turn out
to be untrue but they want to have it
both ways the science is settled it's
unchanging shut up and listen to us we
were wrong oh well you know science is a
process it evolves over time well let's
let's talk about some of the good news
and what this means we have the story
from CNBC Elon Musk expected to serve as
temporary Twitter CEO after deal closes
he also raised an additional seven
billion dollars from friends so we'll
start there
this sounds like really good news I like
Elon Musk right he's going to be the CEO
so he's going to be able to go in with
his own bare hands and start cleaning
things up firing people it also means
parag agrawal is out as soon as this
deal is done and by the way when they
say temporary they're like Elon is going
to temporarily be the CEO until he kills
himself or dies of mysterious
circumstances oh no God oh I have a
feeling he wants to get in there make
some specific changes listen to a bunch
of people and then if you see someone he
thinks is more qualified he'll let them
start executing for him but but here's
where it's also interesting he raised
some money
I think 1.9 billion of the money he
raised came from that Saudi prince who
previously said he was not okay with the
deal so the new conspiracy theory
apparently I don't know you might want
you look this up Ian Elon Musk was
wearing a jacket at the Met Gala that
said New World Order on the back but in
white embroidery on a white jacket so
you couldn't really see it you want to
look at it did it really this is from
investmentwatchblog.com is it let me see
if I can find it as well yeah
Bloomberg confirms Elon is a young
Global leader for Klaus Schwab wef great
reset this is the title from
investmentwatch.com from April I think
this might be fake news a while ago oh
no okay here we go it's like almost a
month three weeks ago it could be I mean
this is this is Grimes that wasn't this
yeah this is this is old
what is that photo there's an old photo
but the 2018 met Gallows the 2018. okay
that says new world oh well there you go
yeah so he was wearing it says novus
ordo seclorum meaning New World Order on
the back well his his takes are
suspiciously based you know because it's
all of it's like the red meat for what
we want to hear you're like oh you're
calling out big Pharma oh you're calling
out all of these people or you're
replying to cerno you know it's what's
going on it was on what a night so you
have this wave of populism and they're
resisting it they're trying everything
to censor it and shut it down no matter
what they do they can't win so they say
okay we need a ringer someone who's
gonna flank the populists who are
calling out this BS and be on their side
and say everything they want Elon Musk
is also the guy who's up running Tesla
plants in in China or whatever or
praising China on Chinese social media
that pretty sure we'll check it at that
but so I I don't I don't necessarily
care for the the crazy idea because what
he's doing is good for Freedom good for
personal responsibility you're never
going to agree with someone 100 and the
thing about Elon is he when you hear him
talk especially about Ai and stuff he
seems genuinely concerned about the fate
of humanity and where we're going so I
it might be genuine yeah I mean I was
saying this
when we were in Nashville and the story
about Elon even discussing buying
Twitter first broke I am optimistic in
some ways I'm also cautious you know I'm
not like a giant Elon fan but I have
liked what he's been saying and I'm
gonna take the evil I don't know over
the evil I know because the people
currently running that website are
absolutely terrible so I I want to give
the guy the benefit of the doubt here
but who knows he I mean we should
consider all possibilities Elon Musk
flanks the Liberty side saying
everything they want to hear oh yeah the
Epstein stuff how come no one's talking
about that oh look at these leftist
organizations trying to shut us down and
then everyone's like yes and really
you're just buying into the same thing
it's two base and what are your gripes
with Elon
um so some of what Tim talked about with
him having plants in China it's not just
that though my point isn't that I
actively dislike him it's just that I I
don't really know him or his agenda well
enough at this point to say I'm a big
fan or that I trust him a big fan I'm a
dude's building Starship star length
those are awesome yeah I'm yeah and I'm
sorry that's awesome I'm a fan of a lot
of the stuff he's doing
I think I don't actively dislike him
like I said I'm very cautiously
optimistic about what he's doing here I
like the things that he's doing but I
don't want to quite sign up for the you
know Elon bandwagons
I'm I'm very cool with everything Elon
is doing for the most part you take a
look at Jeremy's razors they they make
their razors in China I believe and a
lot of people got angry and Jeremy
explained to us is Jeremy boring cosia
of daily wire you can't make these
things here like it doesn't happen so
they tried right and so he's like if we
raise enough money absolutely we're
going to open a plant here and and do
everything and um and charge you three
times more for the razors because there
won't be slaves making them that's and
that's true too and then you've got Elon
Musk praising China the way I see it is
I'm not as concerned about this my
concern is intent and what he's working
on so take take a look at us for
instance here we are on YouTube knowing
we can't talk about the fisa data
release do we not do the show and have
zero reach on any of these topics or do
we say okay we're going to do what we
can with the platforms we have and then
try and find Alternatives Elon Musk is
doing so much good yes he's got you know
praise for China or plant in China but
I'm wondering what the total weight is
going to be if it's like 60 doing really
good things fixing things and then 40 is
in the bad area I'm like it's not
absolute no you got to weigh the good
with the bad and I would agree with you
on that too I would absolutely agree the
one thing about musk that I really do
like and I've mentioned this before is
the fact that he seems to be at least in
his rhetoric very pro-human and also not
just in his rhetoric and his behavior he
has quite a lot of children the man
believes that human life is a good thing
he warns against the birth dearth or the
fact that we're going to experience
serious consequences from being
underpopulated and so he's trying to
encourage people to have more children I
think those are all great things now
that sounds weird though he's got like
seven of them well no I mean does he
he's kind of I just think it's weird for
him to come out and be like
overpopulations of myth it's like that's
a little too on the nose you know yeah I
don't know I just think every other
billionaire on the planet and really
every member of that kind of Elite Class
says the exact opposite it's fantastic
to have a voice who's Bill Gates telling
the truth about it still spreading lives
Bill Gates came out and was dragging
Elon and he was like I I think he's
gonna make it worse the billionaires are
fighting but you know
the annoying thing about Bill Gates is
he's just such a evil person you know
he's he's the kind of guy who's sitting
there he's talking in this interview
about censorship he's the kind of guy
who would be like I don't understand why
poor people have messy homes just have
your maid clean everything for you and
your butler can bring you your scotch
did he actually say that no okay I'm
making a joke okay the point is he says
we shouldn't allow people to have open
communication on the internet and it's
like yeah you're a rich dude who can do
whatever ever you want and you don't
want the poor people to have access to
their to their rights of speech I get it
that's the annoying thing it's this
vapid elitist like why don't you just
have the help clean your floors because
people don't have help they have to do
it themselves but he's this rich guy
who's like why would anyone want this
information dude you are not the Arbiter
of Truth and morality you're some dude
who sold software you are also not a
healthy person either and then he
complained get this he said is Elon
going to allow covid vaccine
misinformation Twitter just censored new
Breaking information
because of your stupid policies so sit
down and shut up you have no idea what
you're talking about old man you don't
think he's a good health man I was I was
thinking about trying The the Bill Gates
diet I want to figure out what he's
eating well you get your gut get really
huge you have to make sure your neck is
sticking forward and then uh hug
yourself a lot when you're nervous
I think that'll get you right to where
Bill's at right now Bill heal up man if
all we get from Elon Musk is this meme
Elon Musk has done the ultimate good it
is neck Bill fix your posture
so he writes in case you need to lose a
boner fast and it's Bill Gates and then
next to it is the pregnant man emoji but
can I just point out how how strange it
is that Bill Gates is wearing a blue
shirt like the pregnant man with a big
gut like an apartment but the haircut
the haircut's the same same haircut
no glasses though so we're not
overpopulated by the way the people are
just Mal aligned at the moment we have
too many people in these small pockets
of cities with not enough rail we it's
hard to get food from the farm to the
city but if we have like low orbit drone
transfer we have we could have like
easily 17 billion people on this planet
right did you see the slingshot they
made for orbit launching where it's like
it's this um tube and they put something
in it and then it spins around like
crazy and then that's what I'm talking
about okay you can put an underground
track where you have a magnet push it so
it goes up and then you kick on the
propellers and take it the rest of the
way it spins really really fast and then
just momentum will get you into orbit
yeah it's an orbit launching and you can
catch things like that from other
planets when you or you slingshot it
towards the other planet the other thing
catches you and then slows you down and
then you're crazy sounds really
uncomfortable imagine imagine if farmers
were like we got a lightest shipment of
corn and they put it in this thing it
spins it and flings in an outer space
and it lands by the time you've got it
it would be popcorn
thrusters in in the stratosphere to
guide it and then once it gets out of
the stratosphere again you or you press
ion thrusters from above to push it back
down and then you kick the propellers
back on to slowly bring it in if it's
lightweight enough the friction won't
destroy it I when I saw the meme that
Elon posted about Bill Gates and the
pregnant man I just I couldn't
understand because he knows we all I
could be wrong we all hate Bill Gates I
mean all the conservatives the one
billionaire they're like no it's Bill
Gates they're even okay with Jeff Bezos
but this was because Bill Gates shorted
Tesla and he said I can't take your
credit when did you do that he's got
he's got a 500 million dollar short
position and Elon said I can't take your
climate change activism seriously if you
have a short against the company doing
the most to fight climate change
I look at this Meme and I'm like it's
like they made a cartoon of Bill Gates
yeah
because I made a cartoon of him yeah um
Elon Musk I have to say that I
definitely admire him because he's one
of the only voices that I've heard being
actively pro-human not pro-life as such
but being very like we need to bring up
the birth rate kids are very important
he does have seven I think he has seven
kids by a bunch of different ladies but
he's doing his part like he's not like
not practicing what he preaches well you
think it's better to have seven kids
with a multiple wives
well I think I think it's better to
bring uh seven children into the world
with one woman I think that would be the
ideal life for those kids but if you are
going to tell people to have a bunch of
babies then you should be doing the same
you know with a bunch of women I don't
know about that I mean who's the father
who's fathering these kids
who's mothering these kids where are the
kids at are they at their moms or their
Eli I think that he had I think he's
probably got a lot of help yeah I don't
hire people to raise his kids and I
agree with you that it's not good to
have a bunch of different kids it's
definitely not yeah I hear in that but
that's why I say it's better to have
seven kids with one lady yeah but
Lydia's I mean he practices what he
preaches right
women with 100 Kids you want 100 you
would have 100 babies
talk about it how great what life would
that would be for my wild animals
he has seven kids with different women
well I just wanted I just want to say
this
how disturbing is it that it's
refreshing to us to hear one of the most
powerful people in the world say that
they don't think there should be fewer
humans right he's probably the only
billionaire that thinks that because
many of them are like futurists and
they're like everything's bad let's uh I
want to make this announcement now guys
because we're moving on from censorship
we have this tweet from me oh oh I'm
excited to announce that timcast.com is
now officially hosted on Rumble videos
cloud services and video hosting this is
step one in utilizing and building more
resilient infrastructure for
communication amid the culture war and
mass censorship
big news just happened PayPal banned a
bunch of Independent Media Outlets Matt
taibi wrote about it the New York Post
picked it up this is terrifying and we
don't know why Russian disinformation or
some other nonsense
when they come out
with this disinformation governance
board
that they mayorkas was like it's not
going to Target Americans no I'll tell
you what's going to happen they're going
to say the story about you know Biden is
Russian disinformation then PayPal and
other Financial Services will ban
Independent Media Outlets that are are
talking about or sharing the story
considering we we did an article deep
diving into the Pfizer data that we
can't talk about on YouTube
fair I think it's fair to say that the
powers that be are going to be not too
happy with what our website is doing
however our web services are now hosted
by Rumble while I'm I don't think Rumble
is completely invulnerable or perfect
it's way better than being on Amazon
Google or any other you know host that's
going to be in Silicon Valley and can
have all these weirdo crackpot rules so
one thing we did is this we've got a
bunch of other stuff happening we're
currently working on but we're
announcing it as it comes so step one
get the website off of big Tech Silicon
Valley there we go it's part of a
different kind of cobal that's forming
but at least it's Market competition at
least we're supporting someone who's
giving the middle finger for now to
Amazon web services in the future Rumble
may become the biggest they may be
Amazon web services but as long as
there's competition things are getting
better
Chris talks a lot about Chris pavlovski
the CEO of Rummel talks a lot about open
sourcing stuff and decentralizing
servers I'm 100 on board with
decentralizing servers when you talk
about open sourcing stuff that's great
but the proof is in the pudding my man
open source the code free the software
go agpl3
yeah we don't talk about this enough
right but AWS and the hosts who allow
people to keep their websites up they
have a tremendous amount of power we
generally look at the big top tech
companies like YouTube and Facebook
Twitter the ones that really allow you
to get exposure but you should be able
to have a website as sort of an escape
hash so you can direct your fans there
in case you do get banned but then it's
the case that like you said Amazon could
end up taking you and and the other risk
is um we use PayPal you know a lot of
people said they don't like it and they
didn't want to use it and I know simply
by talking about what PayPal has done to
these independent reporters and
personalities we run the risk of putting
ourselves on their radar and they gave
no justification for why they banned
these people and in one instance I
believe they said they're seizing the
assets to see like to decide what what
to do with it they've done that with
bank accounts too though Chase was
Banning conservatives I believe Laura
Loomer was kicked off at Chase Banking
there's so many of them that they can't
even bank they can't she couldn't use
Comcast services for her ads I believe
so it's it's far-reaching and that's
just the free market at work and it's
acceptable but Elon musket buying
Twitter is fascism
yes yep thanks Robert Reich so we gotta
do we got we got to do a lot to to
um continually expand our infrastructure
the first step
was um we're definitely looking at
payment processors we're looking at
video like we're already so we're using
rumble's video hosting for All Our
member stuff we're using rumble's cloud
services
the next thing we got to look at is
payment infrastructure but the reason we
did this first was if they take the
website down like any anyone in the
chain says we're not going to service
you we're not going to link your domain
any whatever we're not going to provide
you hosting site's gone
financials we lose money but we'll we'll
figure something out the next step is to
secure this system and then we will be
much more resilient we got PayPal stripe
uh stripe I don't know if stripes on the
site right now stripe is our primary and
then did you mention the other one we
don't have any any other ones um I think
kryptos is very promising for the future
you know they finally started taxing it
properly for the most part so you can
kind of get away with using it for
payments
um and then you don't have to dabble
with the Fiat at all you still got to
pay taxes on it but uh I think that's
that's really really good It's All
Digital all the time and um the Swift
payment system can't mess with it at
least overtly yeah
so here's my question Tim when we look
at Rumble we look at these other
services is there a better way to do
this eventually that we could you know
imagine down the line where there isn't
some centralized service you have to go
to in order to be hosted
yeah you want to decentralized service
you were talking about Mesh networking
which is where all of our devices are a
piece of the server and if one goes down
the server is still up because all the
other pieces are working together uh It
Works near near frequency right now you
can get things like Noster and ostr
um there's another one called Briar I
think Services where you can communicate
when it's not on the internet you don't
need an internet you have a local net
that's kind of the future if we can
somehow link up some sort of global mesh
net you know Tesla was working on
sending electricity through the ocean
and underground to people so we may be
able to Wi-Fi each other oh you mean
actual Tesla Nikola Tesla yeah and so we
may be able to to communicate with each
other through ground I thought you're
talking about Elon Musk I was like
imagine you're swimming in the ocean you
get zapped
it would be I guess it would be Wi-Fi it
wouldn't be electricity would be Wi-Fi
he was obsessed with sending electricity
which was really kind of hard I think
that was hurting stuff and causing crazy
you know amorphisms in the environment
but like is that what do you mean uh
like he would cause he caused an
earthquake one time in lower Manhattan
did he really hold on yeah no no Nicola
Tesla oh it was like in the early 1900s
and they went down to us obviously like
what's going on dude they can eventually
shut him down because it was too much
they shut down his uh
his uh what's it called
Warden Cliff his big tower where he was
trying to project wireless electricity
around I don't know if he was damaging
stuff with that but they didn't sound
like he might have been you ever hear
the story about that dude who made the
radioactive death ray in his garage no
yes yes I did what's the element called
amerisium
americium I don't know how he's
pronounced maybe the word America he was
like collecting uh smoke detectors and
then using the little radioactive bits
and putting it inside like a container
and then it would focus the beam and
then he was like covered in radioactive
like lesions yeah what part of that
seemed like a good idea that well the
part where you would end up having a
death rate yeah I guess was he where was
he what was he going to do that's a
while I know that is wild maybe like the
neighbor's cat kept coming over
bothering him I guess the government
found out and offered him a job but then
he kept making death raise so they just
eventually arrested what did they think
he was going to
what did they think he was gonna do I
don't know but like dude
well it's just like you made a death ray
here's a bunch of money you made more
death Rays for shame no no think about
it they found a guy who made a focused
like radioactive beam that silent
assassination you know you could like be
in a cafe and like point it at some guy
and yeah it looks like it was an Arabic
americium you're just American um 241 is
the chemical yeah so death death ready
people at the cafe Tim Wikipedia calls
him a radio uh nuclear radiation
Enthusiast who built a homemade Neutron
Source at the age of 17. holy crap but
he barely died from the death ray I'm
not sure he died in 2016. so could have
been from multiple different things but
I'm assuming the radiation poisoning
radioactive Boy Scouts
and my name is radioactive Girl Scout
that'd be awesome yeah this is in 2007.
yeah oh that's the second time this is
kind of a second neutral yeah he did it
when he was 17. device found in his
freezer easy
larceny of smoke detectors in Michigan
he was allegedly removing a number of
smoke detectors detectors from the Halls
where were his parents right seriously
oh that's just a little Timmy building
radioactive Death Race I think I think
if you can build a radioactive death way
you could death way you could probably
Escape your parents view you know yeah
probably that's fair that's fair point
his death was rolled as an accidental
result of intoxication from the combined
effects of alcohol diphedra
diphenhydramine yeah diphenhydramine
where did I I don't remember where I
read this story but I remember reading
it they said his mug shot he was covered
in Legions yeah so somehow we were
talking about fighting censorship then
we started talking about Nikola Tesla
yeah he's talking about Mesh networking
we don't censor our death if we could
build a stabilized mesh Network I I'm
really interested in the idea of sending
Wi-Fi Underground through the ground do
you think the effects of Wi-Fi
everywhere would be though man I feel
like it's not good for us I think it's
driving people wacky like squirrely I
think it's heightening people's tension
and your brain starts to get like really
yeah in your eye yeah I think that's
part of it diet and and uh frequency
yeah that might be I've not seen a lot
of evidence about it though but it just
feels like it like studies about how the
Rays affect like women's reproductive
systems and stuff but I don't think
we're ever going to know for a very long
time well it's all non-ionizing
radiation I would carry my phone in my
left pocket from the age from like 2000
to 2014 and all of a sudden one day it
started getting really sore my leg right
where I took where I had it took it out
for like three days and it was no longer
sore I've no longer carry this thing in
my pocket I never never unless I have to
get it somewhere I did the reasonable
thing and I carry myself into my
underwear yeah that's good yeah no
problems
I always actually wondered about that
because when I was on the ground doing
reporting I would wear it on my chest
and the camera would be rolling it'd be
clipped to my chest and I'm like if I
ever get cancer
yeah but it's like you have heart cancer
I feel like we're not we're not capable
of operating as a species without all
this stuff anymore there's no way for us
to disconnect now
we went to um oh we were coming back
from Nashville we went we stopped and we
stayed at this beautiful like Place
overlooking this waterfall but there's
no Wi-Fi and it was really concerned
like I was really like upset for the
night kind of I was like how will I what
am I even worried about like how will I
what fill in the blank how will I
connect with yeah like just connect with
nature man the waterfall smells great
let's get uh we'll get back on track now
we have a story from Fox News Gavin
Newsom savagely mocked as disgusting
transphobe for claiming men can't get
pregnant at abortion rally quote if men
could get pregnant this wouldn't even be
a conversation the governor told the
crowd of abortion supporters you know
what is missing from this headline
though he was mocked by conservatives in
jest as a transphobe because the left
doesn't care that he said this but Gavin
Newsom said that if men could get
pregnant this would be a conversation I
was told back in 2016 by The Daily Beast
that men were getting pregnant you have
that story about the pregnant man what's
he talking about wait so the left is not
mocking him at all that's surprising to
me because they actually eat their own I
mean I am not surprised that
conservatives are ripping on him but and
the left's usually pretty good they
don't care they don't care we saw how
fast they were able to Define what a
woman was when Roe leaked when the
decision links they're like all of a
sudden we know what it is don't make
laws about women's bodies this is why I
don't get sarcastic as a rebuttal to
someone I don't agree with because
they'll take you out of context and make
you sound like I yeah agree with the
argument that men should not be passing
laws on women's bodies oh I completely
agree and that means that the Supreme
Court in 1973 that was all male should
not have enshrined Roe v Wade right
that's right but they didn't ask the law
saying you can't pass a law they what
they said they passed a law saying you
can't pass a law
they told the States you can't they
passed a law that or they made a Supreme
Court decision that states can't pass
laws yeah that's the first amendment
yeah the First Amendment says they said
we're choosing to decide that they can't
choose whether or not to decide if you
can choose that's literally what the
Constitution does like it restricts the
government from doing certain things
this is funny when everybody got mad
about the parental rights and education
Bill like jenkuger of The Young Turks
he's just oh man he's always so useless
but he was like you're you're opposing
free speech and it's like yo The
Government Can restrict itself like
imagine if Ian declared I will no longer
be allowed to talk about freeing the
code they'd be like you're violating
your free speech like no he's choosing
not to talk also I'm curious if Jake
thinks that not being able to teach
creationism in schools is a violation of
religious freedom it's a violation of
free speech teachers should be allowed
to discuss creationism with kids in
secret that's right and say don't tell
your parents what we taught you here
today all right and the math problems
are like what was the one Jesus rose no
one needs to get the animals on his arms
there's two animals each species has
this many species how many animals do we
need to create some Nuance on the
government restricting itself you've got
the federal government restricting the
state government and those are not the
same governments you might argue they're
not restricting them though I mean
they're giving them they're giving them
the freedom no no no no like the first
amendment at the federal level protects
us against State repression as well but
there was a that was a court case
someone was mentioning this on the show
that it didn't used to be that way that
the federal government's const only
referred to itself and the states refer
to themselves but at some point the
federal government superseded all of the
states it had to do with the farmer
Revolt in like 1783 I think I'm not sure
those those years are right but anyways
later well yeah also on this point of it
being a restriction of free expression
to not tell to you know to not allow
teachers to spread their prefer sexual
practices for students I mean like okay
even if that was the case then fine
teachers shouldn't be expressing their
you know perverted sexuality students
but it's not as if there is such a thing
as a right a to have secret
conversations with other people's
children but B to be part of an
institution that the parents are funding
with their tax money and not give the
parents a say in what their children are
being taught there's no such right
actually Sheamus it's the uh 31st
amendment that teachers shall have the
right to have secret conversations with
children about sex and tell the children
not to tell their parents see this is
why I gotta study Civics more man this
is oh that's the constitution in 20
years
I'm sorry if you want to talk about sex
with my child do not pass go do not
collect two hundred dollars straight to
jail
right to jail will you homeschool are
you or will you homeschool I don't know
he's peeing on me right now I haven't
really gotten that far I'm educated him
about not doing not being on YouTube no
I just tell him elephants are not Birds
Brave books great books you have to be
like excuse me sir please don't pee on
me please stop no you know what he does
you know he does he laughs and then he
paints that's great because he likes my
reaction I scream every time
so then he pees oh good for him someone
else laughed until they peed last night
it was a dream I had I don't know maybe
it's a dream you had a dream You Laughed
Until That Wasn't Me No I was watching
scare videos on YouTube and some girl
was like and look down to see if she
peed herself oh my gosh what kind of
stuff are you watching so many things I
don't know what we're talking about oh
yeah Gavin Newsom changed his political
position for convenience oh yes yeah so
I said Pro tip if they say no uterus no
opinion just remind them that trans
women are women and somebody said
sarcasm further entrenches differing
opinions you're literally doing their
work for them by furthering further
adding credibility to the premise even
if you're trying to be funny I'm not
trying to be funny at all I'm trying to
illuminate to them the duplicity of
their own arguments they don't they
don't like using them they don't they
don't they don't care I I tweeted uh
pregnant men have no sane abortion
because they are men I don't care if
they don't care I care if the people
watching care well yeah but the people
who already agree with us I guess you
know what we're looking for is people
who aren't paying attention moderates
yes you know to see the people who
aren't paying attention right not
necessarily moderates they're also
liberals aren't paying attention they
don't know what's going on but I tweeted
pregnant men have no say on abortion
because they are men and I really do
feel like it's a perfect tweet because
it's uh it's it's you literally can't
argue anything about it because like
they're both left-wing positions but
they both contradict they both
contradict so it's like which of your
positions are you mad about so it's like
tell me I'm wrong but which of your
positions sorry Matt are you mad about
that men can't have a say on this or
that pregnant men do have a say on this
side I'm I don't even care anymore I'm
just so tired of the not common sense
like men are not women I don't care I
don't even need to make funnier argument
like common sense is common sense men
are not women and I'm so tired of living
in this clown world it's a clown world
at this point yeah men are not really
able to get pregnant right no no okay no
okay
let's break it down here's what happens
um
Blair white is always the go-to example
conservative trans woman but I bring up
Blair because Ben Shapiro said
in writing
he would use he him pronouns for Blair
because Blair is male but in public it's
it's too complicated to explain to a
person that Blair is male so if he was
like someone said where should I sit oh
go sit by her because he can't if he
says him people would be like where I
don't see him you know where but if the
person didn't know who Blair was and so
what happens then is we recognize that
you know someone who is like a trans man
or a trans woman for ease of of
conversation people might be like oh her
she Etc but then it it translates into a
legal realm where a younger generation
who's growing up with it says then they
are women if you accept this so it
starts with tolerance of being like okay
for the ease and purpose of
communication we'll just say we get it
but then young people are like that's a
woman and so now you have men can get
pregnant when man is defined as adult
human male adult human males can't get
pregnant so I tweeted trans women are
not adult human females because they're
literally not according to every
dictionary to Wikipedia to every
encyclopedia to every understanding and
I got two reactions one was
congratulations Tim you idiot you just
discovered the difference between sex
and gender the others were you're a
bigot that's not true why would you say
this and like now we're going to come
after you and I'm like I didn't say
anything to anybody and can't Target
anybody I didn't insult anybody I made a
fact statement based on Wikipedia that's
all it was yeah well also oh you
discovered the difference between sex
and gender actually there is no such
distinction it was invented by a pervert
and pedophile named Dr John money yes he
was a weir now he was an actual he was a
very what what didn't he had studies
about
um like seven-year-olds that's Kinsey no
oh well money also did so yeah Dr John
money had a a an infant boy given a sex
change at a young age because he
underwent a botch circumcision and then
had Parents raise him as a girl and then
before them killed himself yeah he
forced him and his brother he forced him
to live as a girl and he forced him and
his brother into doing like depraved
acts on camera yes yeah on camera and
filmed it disgusting perverty he pointed
the terms gender identity sexual
orientation he got the DSM to adopt a
term instead of deviants they both
killed themselves this is the
double-edged sword of TV radio internet
is that we see this crazy stuff now
because people have probably been doing
this for Millennia chopping people apart
and doing but now they weren't
celebrating exactly no there was it was
you saw how gross it was at the time and
but the double edge of that is that the
Mind virus can spread like if people
think they're frogs and people don't
feel accepted and they want to be part
of a group they go to become part of the
I'm a Frog group especially for children
too and it's really confusing to tell
them it's interchangeable at any time
you want I mean if you tell a kid
they're a rabbit they're gonna hop
around and ask for carrots that's just
how kids are and you have I'm in New
York City you know you have
nine-year-olds there that are saying
they're transgender and they are
presenting as you know a little girl
presenting as a boy and their their
parents are okay with it and it's like a
status symbol there it's like oh I'm so
loving and accepting and they're putting
it on these kids like this kid's not
they have no idea what they're doing
there's a Libs of tick tock video that
just went up where the mother is doing a
grammar lesson with her child her son
and it's a bunch of sentences one went
on the swing
Sarah rode her bike or Sarah you know uh
yeah like got on you know on her bike or
whatever and it's like which pronoun
would you use and he put they for all of
them and the mom was like why did you do
that and he's like because we don't know
what gender they are and she goes but
look at their names and he goes you said
nothing is a boy or a girl and she was
like but you their names and then she
went uh well I guess I have to give you
an a because I did say it it's like
she's confused that when she tells a
little boy these names are not boy or
girl so he goes I guess I'll use they
because he doesn't know the difference
between a male and a female name I mean
the ideological underpinnings of the
left that have been forced on this
country have actually mandated adults to
become dumber than children is the moral
of that story because they want to throw
out rationalization and reasoning they
don't want you to think I might fear is
that it hasn't even been forced on
people that they've acquiesced or
they've chosen it because they feel so
dissolved over the future no no I think
kids are pressured they are kids are
forced into what the adults however are
you guys can franchise they have no hope
so they they revert no no that's that's
that's that's that's you're missing the
the big picture here we used to grow up
in the real world we used to have
animals we used to watch animals we used
to watch each other we used to be on
farms we used to work hard we used to
recognize that if you didn't wake up at
6am and tell the field you didn't eat
now we have everything we have good
times making soft people they don't they
don't see livestock they don't know how
animals work they don't know where their
food comes from so they're growing up
completely detached from reality that's
what's happening that parent who was
like why is my son doing these things
it's because she grew up in a bubble
world with no requirements so it's just
this confused state of I should have
things for free nothing is real Blank
Slate all of that stuff
you look at people who grow up in rural
areas and they're like better Farm or
that's it no food yeah a couple weeks
ago that said that they never even had
to do I think it was um oh gosh it was
uh the cowboy the the um
philosophical Cowboy someone called her
or something like that uh he said that
he never really had to have sex ed talks
with his kids because they grew up on a
farm so they already knew chickens check
this out you didn't even need to give
the chicken sex out too we have chicken
City they just know we have chickens
sitting out in the basement and I can't
remember who it was the other day said
oh a fight's breaking out and the
chickens were doing it and I was like
bro the the male the jumped on the back
of the female and then started thrusting
and you thought it was a fight another
thing that happened is I had someone say
to me so why would you want to have
roosters do they like do they lay
different kinds of eggs
yes no they do yeah and I was like
roosters are deporting Deport them
immediately
I don't blame people I blame civil I
blame our society but it's like it's
it's a natural process we've come to the
point where we are so pampered where we
have we have factory farms I know a lot
of people dispute the idea but listen
I'm talking about the pink slime that is
chicken nuggets you used to have to go
and you raise the chickens and you're
throwing you know grains or whatever or
you're turning over the wood for the
bugs and then eventually you're like
time to eat this chicken time to eat
these eggs you know it was really crazy
to me and I I mean crazed experience
growing up in a city the first time I
ate my own my own chicken zag I was like
do I have to do anything to it do I have
to clean it can I just sterilize it
should I put hand sanitizer over it Tim
got the dish soap and a sponge out he
was scrubbing that thing already the
only reason I haven't been eating them
is because I'm afraid they're fertilized
they are all fertilized does it matter
no he does get a little half grown
chicken fetus in there when you crack it
no it's like a a little white dot which
is the chicken fetus basically well it's
the spunk from the rooster
um is it okay to eat yes yeah that's the
crazy thing throughout human history
we've had since uh the chickens were
like what 100 A.D that question was not
asked is it a better for you to have a
fertilizer no no no like imagine being a
kid growing up in the year 200 A.D and
actually did you guys see the northmen
they mentioned you know something about
like being a slave like because they
were like Nordic slaves and he's like
you'll go out working with the silkies
silkies are kind of chicken they're so
fuzzy yeah they're fluffy and they
they're funny and they're goofy to make
funny sounds
just hit listen listen
people would walk into the forest and
grab chives right off the ground and go
food and they would walk back and put it
down they'd go hey and they'd all just
eat it it's like that's food you can't
do that I get I get anxiety going in the
grocery store because I'm like what's in
this I'm like is this what is this real
chicken is this you know pump full of
saline what's it probably is it's it's
we're better off with cleaner foods but
to a limit right like that I watched
some documentary about how they mixed
like beef with ammonia to like get rid
of the like the the bacteria from it and
then mix it back into other meat well
even the chickens we have now are like
mutants they're mutant chickens that we
have no they're nothing like I mean the
difference between chickens now and 100
years ago they're flavorless they're
giant they're they're mutants exactly
Good Times create soft chickens that's
right
um Good Times create Mutant Chickens
Mutant Chickens create hard times it's
hard times create normal so here's my
here's my point here's my point
we I remember it was uh like 2014 I got
first chickens ever they laid eggs and
then I was like okay I've never done
this before and I'm uh how old was I
like then this was this is what is this
uh eight years ago so I'm like 26 27 and
I'm like I have never eaten an egg from
a chicken before what do I do and I'm
looking up online do I do I have to wash
it do I have to like cook it to a
certain temperature and it was like it
basically said if you keep your chicken
safe and healthy you can eat it raw and
I was like what no you could salmonella
it's like no that's because of modern
you know poultry conditions and stuff
and I was like really so Timmy's like
I'm going Rocky crack that egg put in a
cup through it yeah do you eat them raw
at all same eye of the tiger no I use
them to make um I've been making like a
a nut bread it's amazing you just mix
some nut powder like Walnut powder and
some almond flour with the egg and then
you microwave it you get a little bun
and then I put cheese and egg and I love
I do birds nest so you make it like you
cut out a little circle in the middle
and then you crack the egg and you can
dip it in it you can make it nice and
runny but the other thing too is uh we
have chives in the yard all over the
place
because chives grow early season and I
just went out and we grabbed a whole
bunch and chopped them up and threw it
in our beef it was so good we have wine
berries we got more flavor than anything
you buy at the store too yeah
refrigerating it can destroy the flavor
especially with tomatoes wine berries
you see these they got Appalachia all
over the place they're little Chinese
raspberries that are everywhere
during wineberry season you walk outside
and you get like two pounds in like 20
minutes you just shuffle them into bowls
but people who live in cities don't know
anything about this so they're just they
are they are like children
so that you know I'm not trying to be
overtly disrespectful I am saying quite
literally
uh 200 300 years ago people had to
mature they had to survive hardship
today it's so good that these people are
confused about whether or not they can
eat an egg yeah no and the food we are
getting is just so bad I think you can
fact check me out I think you have to
eat like eight peaches now to get the
same nutritional value as a peach like
50 years ago yeah everything veggies
it's just I don't know what it is that
would be a they were probably I bet I
bet people would know the egg shells
back in the day you know yeah probably I
bet people would eat orange rind they'd
be like don't waste it of course you
know what I BET's good is putting the
eggshells in your bathtub when you're
taking a bath and soaking in that water
I bet that's really good for your skin
just it just a thought came to me yeah I
was thinking about skin tougher my eyes
so good I had a friend right through
porus I had a friend in Arizona who
lived by what she called a citrus tree
and it was because she was like all the
different Citrus like cross breeds or
whatever kind of Hose weird fruit but
I'm looking at the screen it's true I'm
looking at this tree and it's just got
like 500 oranges or whatever in it and
then I'm like man imagine being some
just you know like nomadic tribal person
and you're looking for food and you come
across this one tree with all of these
fruits and you're like
and you just take it all and you're like
look what I found and everyone's like oh
food because like food's hard to come by
and they're like eating it like crazy
and they're just eating whatever they
can get yeah and not just food oh sorry
it lets you go yeah yeah no you go
Citrus like fruits that have like horns
like a devil because they're so weird
and kind of incestuous they like mix
with all different kinds of citrus you
can get like grapefruit crossbreeds with
lemons crossbreeds with limes you get
these weird funky things that are really
good they're great for humans but anyway
Sheamus yeah no I was just gonna say if
you came across that it's not just that
you found food it's that you found a
very rare and very sweet and very
delicious food nowadays we've sort of
been spoiled by these foods that have
very intense flavors that would not
occur naturally in nature right well
that was redundant but you'll come
across like
historically if someone found an orange
or a strawberry or an apple I mean that
was really a treat for them like this is
delicious and nowadays people like fruit
gross I want a KitKat yeah let's uh
let's let's Circle back we're gonna
Circle back to this uh political story
we have this from The Daily Mail
you guys want to talk about Civil War
let's talk about Civil War Louisiana
advances Bill classifying abortion as
homicide Republican representative
behind the bill says the state cannot
wait on the Supreme Court the move on
Wednesday came two days after the leaked
draft about Roe v Wade Louisiana State
Rep Danny McCormack a republican
introduced the abolition of abortion act
in March
the legislation approved in a 7-2
committee vote now moves to the state's
Full House the Louisiana Bell is one of
the raft of proposals by lawmakers in
conservative states such restrictions
could go further than the so-called
trigger laws and other regulations that
will take effect in some 26 States
should Roe be overturned
so let's talk about this means if
abortion is homicide
that means a lot in terms of what
happens to abortion providers can I ask
you something is there a difference
between the legal classification of
homicide and the legal classification of
murder
if you're to write a law that says X is
homicide does that mean I'm open to
being considered murder but not
necessarily considered murder in every
case or is that a different technology
yeah homicide means a human killed a
human yeah yeah exactly exactly but
they're so so homicide could be
involuntary manslaughter it could be
first degree murder second-degree murder
I'm curious if this is specified in any
way
they're just calling it they're saying a
homicide which means they're they're
granting life rights to the field yes
yeah which means what are they part of
the census I asked this before the show
it's a silly question but like are they
going to classify these these now humans
as part of the census when they're
taking a census come on I mean they're
not human they're not people yet well
they're not giraffes man they're not
people though they're just they're
developing fetus humans they're not
people until they get a birth
certificate legally no uh that would
that that's the logic they used to keep
slaves in well that's the law That's the
Law right now if you want to change the
law and say that they're people on
conception no no no no the law isn't
that you gain person heard with a birth
certificate
there's there's no law that says there's
no I mean there's no person until
there's a a personality no that's not
true or until it's legally yeah
let's look at what a person is yeah look
actually that's a good idea let's define
I mean it's a philosophical distinction
right but I would actually make the
argument that the distinction between
you know so so I guess you can make an
argument there that there are persons
who aren't human right but every human
is a person you can't not Grant rights
to a living human being well a person is
a the body of a human being that that's
been the worst civil rights violations
in our country's history is when we've
tried to Define personhood and who is or
who is not worthy enough to be a person
so this is this is where I think the uh
the abortion issue is very much
um our second Civil War Catalyst they
they had actually argued in in pre-civil
war that slaves didn't have personhood
that they didn't have the same rights
the Constitution didn't apply to them
they weren't they they had no personhood
you cannot allow someone to Arbitrage
rarely decide when a human being is a
person or women weren't even granted the
same rights just a couple decades before
Roe was was passed yeah well the
argument I would make and part of why
I'm saying that there are the persons
who aren't human is like so for example
it is a little tricky
definitely it's a little tricky
definition wise and I appreciate asking
the question because my my first thought
was well maybe it's a false distinction
but also I know that like as Catholics
we will use the the phrase person to
sometimes apply to the the members of
the Trinity but that said when you're
talking about human beings specifically
and people try to create this
distinction between a human and a person
to me that sort of smacks of the
arbitrary distinction between gender and
sex I think it's just a false
distinction created so that you can do
depraved things you have right now Ian
what you're saying is
these human beings are not people
because we haven't written the paperwork
for them basically yeah legally so but
that but that's not there's seven
definitions of the word person which is
annoying but I'll pick the sixth one
because I think that's the one this is
from Miriam Webster uh one such as a
human being a partnership or a
corporation that is recognized by law as
the subject of Rights and duties so if
they change the law they become people I
guess by that definition the point is
they're they're you asking for paperwork
to it I I reject outright that means you
would assert the right of the state to
say we've decided that Ashley's not a
person for these arbitrations so do they
counter the census that's that's a
question for uh the census for this
Governor not for personhood Ian can I
ask you something because the birth
certificate also mentions the sex of the
child are they ambiguous with respect to
their sex prior to getting a birth
certificate because of that if you don't
know what the sex is yeah but there was
tort law for years and years and decades
in this country that recognize The
Unborn as persons as regards to you know
inheritance and different things like
that I mean we had those laws when the
14th amendment was ratified identifying
tort laws identifying The Unborn as
persons and it could also be considered
I mean there are people who have also
been punished and uh you know for for
killing a woman who was pregnant and
yeah you kill a baby in the world but
you were about to explain I'm sorry I
cut you off I think Ian asked you a
question yeah
so tort laws I mean there there are laws
that from what I understand and I'm not
you know a legal scholar but they were
laws that were like kind and not laws
but they were recognized for the most
part it's like common law in the United
States but tort law is mostly refer to
property
um but there were tort laws in terms of
inheritance for The Unborn in the United
States and what's interesting is the the
Roe v Wade decision they hinged it so so
strongly on the 14th Amendment and this
you know right to privacy but when the
14th amendment was ratified we had these
tort laws recognizing The Unborn as
persons and you know having rights to
certain things so it was just the mental
gymnastics that was done in this in the
road decision in general just as an
abuse of discretion and
constitutionality is insane and also
when someone uses a phrase like we found
this in the penumbra of the show right
you can say there could be a chance that
this is mental gymnastics we saw this
was like they said it was enumerated
rights followed by enumerated problems
right and they just first of all there's
not a right to privacy at all there's no
right to privacy in the Constitution you
have some right to privacy as it refers
to the Fourth Amendment and you know
unwarranted searches and seizures but
you don't have a right to privacy at all
well this is interesting what is this
I have to so concerning the tort law you
mentioned is it so like if a woman is
pregnant and the father dies his inherit
and say the mother and the father dies
you'd have to look it up because I don't
want to you know say the wrong thing but
there was tort laws that recognize them
I want PubMed it says prenatal tort law
and the personhood of The Unborn Child a
separate legal existence but I can't
find I'm looking for doctor so I have a
docket from the Supreme Court I just
pulled it up I got to look into it a
little bit more there's a fantastic book
opinions from 1850 to 1880 suggests that
an unborn child is a person within the
meaning of the 14th Amendment to the U.S
Constitution fascinating so I'll have to
I have to look up what this is uh yeah I
want to read so and so many people think
that the argument is just oh you know I
think abortion's moral but no there was
serious abuse of discretion as it comes
to the way they decided this there was
populationist theory in the clerk's
memos there was incredible influence
from populationist when they decided Roe
it is incredible when you look into it
you look from the clerk memos and
everything like that there were so many
more things that influenced even Ruth
Bader Ginsburg said it wasn't about
women at all it wasn't about women no
abortion is not about women it's about
the abortion I mean it's about the
abortion industry profiting off of
slaughtering unborn children and it's
about allowing men consequence free
access to women's bodies like
consequence free sexual activities about
keeping people that are poor from having
50 kids yep it's sad but that's a big
part of it it's very sad I agree because
like human life is only valuable if that
person is born into a middle class upper
class family yeah I mean that seems to
be the the dominant modern the challenge
here with not recognizing personhood for
The Unborn is like a baby at eight and a
half months who's not yet been born
inside the womb next to a baby that is
eight and a half months from the point
of conception that was emergency
delivered via C-section
that baby that's out of the womb can't
be touched but the baby that's still in
the womb of the exact same development
could be executed that is the way to go
I agree with you that is so weird you
had northumb talking about not
resuscitating babies
and then having a conversation about
what to do next is what he said this is
the question I have look evil I I can
understand an argument from the point of
uh first trimester nothing after nothing
second or nothing third in terms of
abortion but when you're talking about a
viable baby that outside the womb of its
own independent life could not be harmed
under penalty of law and a baby exactly
the same but in the womb can be
something doesn't make sense it seems
like all these laws were written way
back in the day before modern technology
where you could do an ultrasound or like
see the baby struggling during an
abortion process trying to avoid the
forceps or whatever like uh before
before you knew the gender before it was
born because the 14th Amendment
specifically says after they're born and
they're no their standard was much
different so their standard was
quickening back then for abortion when
they did have abortions even back in the
day the standard was quickening which
was when you felt the baby and then when
they felt they found out that oh this
dude's actually alive a little sooner
than that they amended it to hey you
know we should not be doing these as
soon as we know that they're there it
was as they thought that was conception
they didn't know that quickening was not
okay I'm pregnant this is when the baby
like it's just what is quickening
quickening is when you can feel the baby
moving and so they had no idea that that
was not conception yeah exactly and so
the um the development of embryological
Sciences made it so much more clear that
it is a living person I mean I've
mentioned this before in the show 95 of
biologists surveyed say life begins at
fertilization and so the science is very
much settled on this issue I would say
it makes it very clear that it's a
living organism whether or not it's a
person is a legal discussion well what
do you call a living human
is a living human not a person it
depends on what stage they're in if it's
the two days after conception it's It's
You could argue it's about to be a human
living and then it develops into human
but it's not really a I mean the whole
idea of a person is that it's got a
personality that it can communicate that
it's a person you know I just I don't
want to be on the wrong side of that
argument right because like I said the
worst civil rights violations in our
country's history and the world have
been when we've tried to decide who is
or who is not a person and I just don't
want to touch it I don't want to be on
the wrong side of history and that's
just well we're kind of creating history
right now yeah and I don't want to be on
the wrong side of it there was there's
no right or wrong here we just gotta do
the best we can who cares well Ian so
here's why I would push back on that so
I think there are arguments that I could
make against your your definition of
personhood and in favor of the idea that
the unborn child is a person at all
stages but I believe that the burden of
proof is actually strongly on the the
one who says it isn't a person I think
you actually have to prove that because
for example if I'm going to detonate a
building
I need to know that there is no person
inside of it I can't say well there
might be we don't know it's a complex
philosophical discussion about whether
there's a person in there we're just
going to detonate it and if you know
someone dies someone dies I think we all
recognize you need to be 100 perfectly
clear that the activity you're partaking
in is not the killing of a person before
it's permissible at all and that hasn't
been proven and it hasn't been proven I
mean because it is a person but I don't
even hear left Wingers I don't even hear
people in favor of abortion try to
advance an argument that it's not a
person they just say it isn't or they
say you haven't proven it is a person
it's a lump of cell I mean without I
don't want it to make an emotional
argument you had a baby you had one
inside of you so you understand I guess
it I would think that it starts to
develop a personality before it leaves
the the female body at some point
whether or not you can interact with it
or not what does personality have to do
with someone whether or not someone's
person a personality is derived from the
person you know it's just these vague
terms no if if there is a mute deaf
child we don't say they have no rights
well so like I would say it has a
personality like it might react
different to different stimuli in the
womb so that it's a type of personality
you could argue person yeah this one
doesn't like to get rid of them what
about when someone's uncut I mean when a
person is unconscious they're not
displaying any traits of personnel no
but they've already been established
it's a person that's unconscious but
let's say someone finds like what if
he's the biggest person in a hospital
like a naked person in the forest who is
completely unconscious and not
responsive but has a heartbeat do you
just be like that's not a person I can
do whatever I want to it do they have
personhood if they have no no mind if
you find bro if you find an unconscious
woman and you do anything to that woman
you're going to prison first so if you
find a a body someone like you said I
don't think I don't know if vegetable is
probably an insensitive way to talk
about it but if someone's has basically
zero brain activity and there's just a
heartbeat and a body then is it a person
so yes yes but also we'll go to prison
for doing something to that body like
physically harming it and then even then
there isn't really uh a perfect
comparison there right because in the
case of an unborn child we know that we
are what 99 percent sure that they will
end up developing all of the cognitive
faculties that you're mentioning a
person in a coma lacking yeah this is
why I brought up birth control at the
beginning if that's also like Plan B can
I also mention something I just want to
say the person the definition of
personhood given by Google is the least
helpful thing the least helpful
definition the quality or condition of
being an individual person
thank you so much what about conjoined
twins what about conjoined twins are
they not people the other definition
they give personhood or personality is
the status of being a person oh thank
you thank you so much yeah
in or as if in a play that's the
definition of person come on if you look
at the Supreme Court docket it says
according to Webster's Dictionary a
child is a quote person not yet of the
age of majority so we are using the word
person in the definition but the
understanding is that someone who is
small is just a person who hasn't
reached for example the age of consent
this is why we understand that children
cannot consent to sex although this has
gone somewhat by the wayside in the age
of trans children but this is something
that they were mulling even back when
they were looking at abortion in the
first place I just think it's kind of
simple
can you kill a human unprovoked for no
reason
only if you're in the military
only if they can't make noise well
that's not I said no reason in the
military military if you see a kid walk
well yeah you get everything you're
supposed to have a reason you definitely
can't just go kill a kid oh you can they
have the power to and they have done it
in the past yeah and you look at my live
massacre in Vietnam you can physically
do a lot of things the point is under
the law as you so yeah but they'll get
protected look at the myelin Massacre
all those guys got protected except for
the captain that initiated that massive
point is is there but did that did the
children have personality is there a
reason yes war was the reason can you
walk up to a random person and just end
their life the answer is no is a fetus a
human being the answer is yes therein
lies the major conundrum the left has to
has to define a way when life begins
otherwise abortion if if you were to if
you were to operate under the pretext of
the 14th Amendment as per Roe v Wade the
actual ruling should be that you can't
perform an abortion because it would
violate the equal rights under the law
of the of the fetus which is a human
being now they'll try and use the
argument that it says persons born but
then you run to the conundrum which I
mentioned earlier a baby who is born at
eight months and a baby who is still in
the wind eight months are identical in
every way one doesn't have rights
because of the layer of Flesh around it
yeah that's modern technology is is
forcing us to change the law no no
that's not modern technology there were
many circumstances in which a baby was
born at eight months and survived eight
months is viable without you know I mean
you might need some medical intervention
but let's say eight let's say let's say
nine months and one baby went a little
bit longer than nine months the law
right now is a baby at nine months fully
delivered and healthy and crying and a
baby that hasn't been delivered one can
legally be killed because they haven't
been given yeah saving a vagina they're
the same thing I know when I got a 40
ultrasound it was this he looked just
the same when he came out and he'd go in
the same little position I'm like you're
the same little kid that I saw yeah oh
gosh I just saw a picture somebody on
Twitter show who was it ah they showed
up ultrasound and the baby arms up yeah
he's sleeping like that and I want to
mention it same thing I mean yes it is
the case that in 1973 our prenatal
science was not as developed as it is
today we didn't know enough but that's
no excuse It's horrifically
irresponsible to say well we don't know
a whole lot about the circumstances in
the womb so we're just gonna err on the
side of go ahead and kill it well and
even then you know they said it should
be rare right and that was the big thing
even Joe Biden was saying it should be
rare and we've gone so far that not only
is it legal and acceptable but they're
shouting their abortions it's constant
it's they make it like it's removing a
wart and it's a simple easy procedure
that has no consequences and I just want
to mention one thing I know I'm sort of
talking about the science here I think
it's straightforward I think it's common
sense um that it is a person the entire
time it is a human being because that's
the only reason anyone wants to kill it
you wouldn't be killing it if it wasn't
a human person who you would be
responsible for I just don't want to
conflate the word person with human at
this point because of their legal
definitions yeah what would happen if
you took a newborn puppy and just put it
outside and walked away
not much Cassandra would come kill you
yeah no I mean yeah I'm not sure what
the uh animal protection laws are but I
assume you would get in trouble for
something like that aren't there laws on
the books that prevent you from abusing
animals or neglecting that I think you
can have puppies outside well yeah I
mean if you leave a dog outside right
that's an animal but I think Tim is
saying if a dog died through your
negligence is that if you take if you
take a newborn puppy and put in your
backyard just walk away oh like a
newborn puppy that needs to be with its
mother I didn't say anything I said what
would happen if you did it I don't know
nobody would get nobody would care
like you if you took a baby and walked
outside put it in the grass
even helplessness they are helpless for
so long my kid has no idea what he's
doing like he falls over on his honestly
starts crying he's like I don't know
let's let's let's jump over to this next
story real quick and I'm gonna start
with a meme oh yeah let's do it the meme
is um it's an NPC Guy saying who
radicalized you and then the Chad gamer
guy says no one I'm just a normal person
from 10 years ago the reason I start
with this for this segment is that I
posted this because it's funny and then
all the progressives are like you're
showing your true colors we have 10
years of progress the people in the
1950s said the same thing about
interracial marriage and then I was like
and you know what I'm saying the same
thing about
HHS secretary Becerra argues transgender
surgeries for minors should be aided by
the government yeah I'm I'm the kind of
guy who's going to be like we should
expand civil rights for people and leave
kids alone and you're telling me it's
progress that the government should be
funding surgeries for minor sex changes
yeah okay well dude please remember okay
with saying notified the Roman Empire
notice that time can pass and you can
regress yeah exactly well this is what I
want to point out I don't know how to
explain this to people but let me try to
put it succinctly the fact that people
in the past at some point opposed a good
thing that ended up happening does not
mean that opposing change is a bad thing
in all instances that is the dumbest
possible argument you can make for your
business oh you're against things
changing well people were against civil
rights gotcha people were also in favor
of eugenics yeah the progressives not
just people the Progressive Movement the
left they still are yep but now it is
not socially acceptable so when I say
I'm about a humble normal person from
2012 and they say ha that means you're a
conservative uh does that mean you're
still in favor of eugenics does that
mean if you're not you're a conservative
any anyone on the left who opposes
Eugenics must be a conservative along
with every other person on the right
what they are saying is you need to
mindlessly accept every every single
social change that is pushed on You by
everyone above you and if you don't do
so you are far right that is their
entire argument be a sheep go with the
crowd do what you're told if you stand
up against the modern Orthodoxy which is
going to be different five years from
now then you are worthy of contempt you
should be excluded from public life
you're not truly a human being you don't
have rights we're not going to listen to
you speak you are a far-right
psychopathic bigot it's part of why I
don't like calling people left us
because then they just turn it around
and start yelling right right right they
can tell me I'm on the right that
doesn't bother me
they are the ones who do it and created
it but they it's all this identity crap
like for real we just got to use common
sense I think but then even that that
term Common Sense gets abused it's funny
because I like that I feel like no
amount of evidence will will show you
why you're wrong Ian about what well
about you you always say this all the
time like we can't say left we can't say
right you compared me to Mao for saying
left and right yeah he talked about
right now and then no matter how many
times I tell you like the left being an
umbrella term describes a kind of person
that are authoritarian that believe fake
news and then no matter how many times
we invite them on the show they react
the exact same way like screaming
lunatics who don't actually want to have
their ideas challenged I think it's and
I keep showing you the evidence of these
things we try to do there's definitely
examples yeah but to generalize is where
it becomes dangerous yeah like at a
certain point you know but you
generalize that unborn children aren't
persons
you have a pattern of behavior we've
exhibited exhibited this pattern of
behavior in like nine out of ten times
when we've invited the so-called left
onto the show nine out of ten times they
behave the exact same way they create
nonsense statements try to use the
invite as some kind of own or tried it
in some way attack the show because so
it's like what do we do at this point
when I'm like hey you're a person who's
pro-choice and you're very angry would
you like to come on the show and then
they say something ridiculous like I
want to punch you in the face then
you're already playing identity politics
if you're like I'm gonna go after
someone that's pro-choice
they have distance themselves from
people who believe the way that we it's
not us who's putting them in the bubble
and this is I mean there's there's
studies that showed that conservatives
will follow left-leaning people
and the left will not and they're
they're able to quantify that because
there is a difference and the people
that are more on the left do not consume
different opinions whereas people on the
right do they're also significantly more
likely to cut someone out of their life
or having different political they're
talking about like radical ideologues I
mean those are there are people that are
like well this is this is the difference
between the left and the right okay so
left-wing people will go you don't agree
with every single part of my Niche
left-wing ideologic like my ideology
that I discovered uh online two weeks
ago therefore you're anti-human and I
can never talk to you again and then
people on the right are like someone
told me that they're okay with
infanticide should I still be friends
with them let me show you this from
ground.news it's called Blind spotter I
pulled up myself 56 of the news timcast
interacts with on Twitter leans left 20
to Center 24 is Right leaning Michael
malice fairly balanced if you look at
Michael Mouse's profile you can see that
it's about 45 left leaning maybe about
20 to 25 Centrist and then 20 right jack
besobic a conservative gets most of his
news two-thirds from conservative
sources 60 Center vosh has no uh
right-wing sources so why is it that I
who have rather left leaning policy
positions and considered on the right
because I consume news across the board
even though I do kind of consume most
news from the left vosh gets none of his
new from the right at all because
they're creating that they're creating
the tribe they're the ones doing this
they're putting the boxes if I'm on the
left then anyone to the right of me is
on the right you gotta understand that
okay so it's all relative well so here's
the thing I wouldn't argue that it's all
relative but you're right that there's
an element of subjectivity that comes in
there we see a lot of left-wing people
who will say things like
oh our political leaders on the left are
actually right-wing by European
standards but even that isn't completely
honest because the stance that most of
them have on abortion is far far left
compared to anything that's enshrined
legally in Europe but
we need to strive for some objective
standard and say like okay if if you
support like you know perverting
children if you support like forcing
perversions onto children and killing
unborn children
and you know even other things that
aren't so uh necessarily intrinsically
bad in that way like just left-wing
Economic Policy some of those are
horrible some of those there's a
discussion to have like you are on the
left but they will try to argue that
person's actually a moderate because
from my stance they're on the law it's
like well you actually have to look at
the political some sort that out assume
what they who even they are I don't even
know what that means that they would
I'll explain it to you so I've actually
um over the past four or five years
repeatedly referenced these um tribal uh
um data maps showing the left and the
right they completely exist if you look
at Twitter's data Maps I've done
extensive reporting on the different
tribal spaces the digital they call them
digital countries or digital National
Nations you have like the progressives
that you have the staunch Democrats you
have the the conservatives then you have
the Republicans there's like even a
difference then you have like marketing
which is on the border of progressive
it's really weird Twitter marketing
brand fans border the Democrat voter I
can actually I've actually done I've
done so many segments talking about all
of these things now I think for you Ian
you need to look at those data maps and
see they exist there is a there it's the
picture I drew of the two you know two
umbrellas pushing up against each other
where you have the right sphere of
influence on the left sphere of
influence here's blind spotter again
take a look at Luke we are change our
good friend lucrutkowski his news is
perfectly split between conservative
left and Center that's pretty balanced
Sour Patch Lids most of her news from
Liberal left-wing sources look look me
up Sheamus guys
Ian Crossland that's a crown on My Head
by the way in Crossland is gets almost
none of his news from the right that's
interesting tell me where I get most of
my news I'm in the middle because that
is what it's all about the left and the
right combined form one large Center I
think that's actually very interesting
Ian because most of the people I'm
looking at on this don't really have a
wide spread on the middle and you seem
to have a very wide spread on the middle
that was interesting yeah yeah I don't
know who's deciding oh that's not shame
so that is not me Sheamus underscore
that's hilarious not underscore Sheamus
underscore Coughlin yeah other Sheamus
underscore
yes see 68 left look at this this this
far right right wing conservative bigot
mostly interacts with left wing named
sources because we know what they think
but you're right it could just be me
make making fun of doing research right
you want to know what your enemy I mean
obviously any good warrior wants to
understand what their enemy thinks and
if this is really a social war or a
culture where you've got to go pull from
all sources and that doesn't mean you're
on the left if I go no hang out with a
bunch of people that want to kill babies
and transgender their six-year-olds it
doesn't mean that I'm a leftist and if
you put me in a box if you say that and
I hear you say that out loud that I'm a
leftist it's gonna mess with my mind
isn't it hilarious though that everyone
instantly knows that murdering babies
and transgendering children is like the
left how do you like how much more do
you have to do to convince people that a
group is evil liberalism is it can
become dangerous ideology and the
liberal radicals in the French
Revolution sat on the left side of the
aisle so that term gets applied to them
but it doesn't mean that people are in
some box somewhere this is you've even
acknowledged us multiple times they're
meaningless phrases they just kind of
identify a source of some sort of tribe
but there's so many in like miniature
intricate tribes within tribes that to
coagulate them for to get a point across
I feel like you you know take a look at
how we classify animals right
do you know how we classify animals yeah
like phenotype genotype stuff like
chordata or whatever I'm not I'm not a
biologist
yeah I think you under you don't
understand the the the the concept of a
parent tree right
well yeah I understand that concept okay
so when we say the left we're talking
about a parent's job you're talking
about like a cultural idea not not like
a not like an animal species that's
understanding science we're not being
scientific when we say left and right
this is just a cultural idea kind of
thing it refers to tribe that's why the
left calls me right wing because I'm not
in their tribe and the right calls you
left wing because it's all relative
because the right knows the political
arguments and so they look at me as my
political arguments not which tribe
we're in so the way I've described it is
at some point we had this American
sphere of influence which was had a left
and a right that mostly agreed on
American values in a constitutional
republic at some point a multicultural
democracy emerged to our left with crazy
ideas 2012 and they think everyone in
the original sphere of influence is
right wing in that sphere of influence
the right and the left still call each
other right and left that's very
dangerous too because they're tribal
signifiers tribes is a very dangerous
way to go but that's that's the reality
it exists
tribalism's human nature yeah and using
those words left and right like fortify
that nature that dangerous nature of
treatment it's just a way to explain an
idea dude but it is uh it is a way to do
it I just don't think it's a it's an
effective way and as a journalist it's
not a it's not an accurate way to
portray like reality
notice I I want nothing to do with them
what is them the left what does that
means
my child about sex in third grade that's
who I want so let's let's let's let's
talk about it very very simply
when I come out and say
kids should not be getting sex change
surgery
that is overtly supported by prominent
left-wing individuals not all of them
however
the other left-wing individuals who
aren't advocating for it call me a
transpho bigot or a liar for calling it
out yep when I say Joe Biden did illicit
dealings in Ukraine and that's a fact
there are people who don't care that he
did like that he did or will will just
tell me I'm a liar but every person on
that side will say well I don't know if
that's true but you must be right wing
gun yeah exactly if it goes against
their tribe you're the other so when we
talk about the left we talk about
a collection of policies and ideas that
are not intrinsic among every person on
the left but they all defend it
progressives hate neolibs neolibs hate
progressives these are massive
generalizations all of them do they all
of them hate all of them all it's like
come on dude you're a journalist that's
not a way to get specific about things
Ian
just because I make a general point that
is true does not mean I said every
single Progressive hates ever just said
it you said they all hate them and they
all hate them progressives hate neolib
that's a generalization it's a fact I am
Progressive as hell man I don't say
people it is a fact that if you go into
it says which I don't think you
understand Nuance is the problem if you
go into a room full of progressives and
say how many of you like neolibs they'll
go boo boo and one person might be back
they're not that bad what about this we
split this for all the boys and girls
you think we're really going to get
along if that's how we think about
things in here yeah I I think
they are actually girls yeah
Nancy Pelosi does not like AOC
AOC does not like Nancy Pelosi they both
routinely go at each other and rag on
each other and then they vote together
if they're catty man it's not it's not I
don't care about the political party
it's irrelevant I think that's a
generalization about women and that is a
caddy thing for people to do you're
ignoring the point answer the argument
they both don't like each other they
both publicly expressed disdain for each
other they vote together against their
their their their their Collective
enemies that's the problem of politics
we quantify these by saying there are
two parent tribes that are opposed to
each other the left and the right
Libertarians do not get along with
conservatives on a lot of issues
conservatives don't get along with
Libertarians a lot of issues they don't
hate each other though but they will
vote together on most issues like the
pro-life issue right now you see Dave
Smith you see Michael malice very much
Against The Establishment the cathedral
progressives lined up to vote for Joe
Biden even though they say they hate him
that's why we say they are the left
because there are certain things they
would support even if they don't like
them but they wouldn't support Mike
Pence Mike Pence is the other tribe
there's a parent sphere of influence
called the left and a right they are not
absolute there are some overlap but it's
overwhelmingly two different spheres of
influence they they are unified in a way
I I was not allowed into a mom's group
using my name because of my
right-leaning politics in a very liberal
City
I I get the I have problems when we
people use past actions to Define future
like say I think there was a best that
is actually the best careful because
okay in the past there was like I think
it was black violence statistics there
was a bunch in the past a lot of like it
was like some random number 20 of all
these crimes were committed by this kind
of person this black people so therefore
black people are 20 or five times more
likely to do this than white people but
you're assuming the future based on what
they did in the past so they were just
digging it out of context because it was
black on black crime Ian also I think
projecting but I don't think this
argument works because you're saying
that there have been unfair
generalizations in the past therefore we
should dispense with the idea of
generalizing Alternatives no I'm saying
if someone made some decisions in the
past it doesn't mean that in the future
they are part of a tribe sure but like
when if there has been a consistent
thread throughout the entire history of
a group such as the left where basically
anytime they've come to power they have
oppressed people every time they've
majorly seized power on the extreme left
they
no I'm not saying that the right hasn't
but when we talk about the left there
are certain threads that we can see
through so they they they are there's
authoritarianism of all I never said
there was I never said there wasn't I'm
saying when you look at the common
threads on the left it's fair to say
that this is what the left is about
there's a reason to use that term to
label ideologues in our country it's not
fair so then you're making his argument
it's not fair to find the left and right
differently there are common threads are
there not common threads on the left you
saying that the common thread of the
left is authoritarianism and oppression
yeah that's a Common Thread for Humanity
okay that's fair but I think that when
you look at left-wing ideology it breaks
down social structures in a way that you
need the imposition of authoritarian
rules with their specific ideology to
shift the social structure we saw that
in Revolutionary France it when the left
was accepted when they first came to be
we saw it everywhere that there was a
revolution where the left took power
afterwards we see it in uh in Germany we
see it in Chile sure I'm not no I'm not
saying the right doesn't become
authoritarian or violent either that's
not I don't I don't think
authoritarianism is the right way to
define what the tribes are necessarily
today certainly the left is
overwhelmingly authoritarian I would say
that the left's tendency is always
towards becoming authoritarian and I
would also say that when we look at the
common threads they're basically always
against the Catholic Church they're
always against the family they're always
against the traditional order basically
everywhere you see the left they're
always against the traditional order yes
and the right is typically for tradition
yes but the issue right now is the right
has a spattering of moderates within it
who have rejected the authoritarianism
of the current left and thus you end up
with a more libertarian right and a more
authoritarian left and part of me
wonders if that's just a consequence of
the fact that one group happens to not
be ascendant so when the right is not in
power it's going to attract more
moderates in people who feel they're
being persecuted by the left yeah I mean
vice versa look at look at gab for
instance uh gab has banned discussion of
porn you know they're they're not okay
with it and so but they're also not uh
institutionally powerful so no one's
threatened by that if the law of the
land was that certain political advocacy
was not allowed moderates would start
moving away saying we don't like the
idea of the government imposing its its
ideas ideology on us
let's go to super chats it is time if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and remember
if at any point you don't agree with
anyone on the show you put a one in the
chat and smash the like button and Super
Chat and explain to us
um what you disagree with and we'll
we'll do our best to read those yeah
all right vasht says YouTube brought to
you by Pfizer when can we chat on
timcast again so um shout out to the
splc who wrote a hit piece on timcast
IRL and their smear was that uh their
smear was that people super chatted us
naughty things and I'm like I have no
power over that it's like I didn't win
those it's a good thing that uh the
super chats come from Tim directly he's
writing them all himself we have like
one guy it's like all the money and they
were like chimcast IRL makes an average
of two thousand dollars per night but
some of them are bad and it's like tell
YouTube I guess I don't know like what
am I supposed to do about that there are
work like YouTube Auto restricts words
and people get mad about it I don't know
it's not us it is what it is
all right I see a lot of people are
smashing that like button seriously
thank you so much
all right let's see we got the core Saga
says inspired by your call to create
culture I'm now at 900 plus pages into
the all-new Naval Voyage into the
unknown you said we need a naval Voyage
novel the most epic historical fiction
Saga since Homer's Odyssey with a Sci-Fi
twist let's talk interesting the core
Saga
little self-aggrandizing to describe it
that way Beyond I'm very proud of you
and I'm very happy for you for creating
culture because a lot of people are not
doing that and so I I very much want to
encourage what you're doing there's a
big difference between putting the pen
to paper and just thinking about putting
the pen to paper it's so true it's so
true so many people have it we've talked
about this in the show before so many
people have ideas it's like okay are you
gonna do something with it please do it
it doesn't take much you just do it keep
going amen and you know what if you're
in the if you're watching this right now
and you have an idea you want to build
culture do it do it please do it we need
it
all right Leif Hagin says you guys hear
human events bought the post of
millennial today wondering what this
entails that they hands down they
announced it a couple days ago it was I
don't know the purchase was today but
you work for the Post Malone I do I do
I'm their senior culture contributor oh
yeah did you know that they were was
this before or after they got bought
this was like during the buyout but we
announced it at the same time as the
buyout but I'm so excited the team is
just awesome everyone we have on there
great more power you know yeah joining
forces yeah unite The Chronicles of
Chris says I'm I'm still not inclined to
believe musk is pro-free speech when
he's on good terms with Chinese
communists it's an interesting point
Fair Point yep
that's what I said you all yelled at me
no okay
shame
John Paul Mass Isaac is suing Adam
Schiff CNN daily Basin Politico he's the
guy who Hunter Biden left his laptop at
his shop I heard that that's crazy yeah
I did hear about that I wonder what's
gonna what's gonna come of that can you
believe in a crackhead left his life
somewhere leave it fake news the
crackhead did not leave the laptop ever
come on man yeah that's uh that's an
interesting one and I if they settle out
of court they're gonna go it was
nuisance money it was just news Michael
Brogan says I've never seen as much from
my 2A Bros on Twitter until two weeks
ago meanwhile AK guy was banned and
unbanned from Instagram in the last 48
hours the top levels are definitely
panicking happy to see it Mima type says
open source code can be just as secure
if not more than closed source security
is from good code not secret code
internet sites and government agencies
use Linux all over which is 100 open
source and it's plenty secure Linux
rocks I'm told ah here we are Alex says
happy Cinco de Mayo timcast crew Sheamus
and Miss Sinclair drink the expensive
tequila tonight we do have we do have
nice I can't believe I was I was
expressly excluded as a member of the
Tim cast crew on Cinco de Mayo
Cinco de Mayo of my life and and do you
all know what today celebrates I know
it's not the Mexican Independence Day I
don't know what it does it every year
what are you doing go ahead and tell us
Tim what Tim it's the celebration of the
victory of the Battle of Puebla that's
right every year he tells us through the
Battle of Puebla that's right that's
right us took place on May 5th Cinco de
Mayo
story again
oh Cinco de Mayo that's a different
story yeah that's when they're five
males there were five males on the table
and the he took one of them that's true
George the joke is that it was a
shipment of Spanish mayonnaise coming to
the new world when it sank oh my gosh
that was the Lesser known Boston Tea
Party when they sank the ships with the
mayonnaise on it and we called it the
Cinco de Mayo
well how else do you think they got it
Tim where are you gonna get your
mayonnaise yeah they made it here's
here's the question you take the
mayonnaise a person probably you ever
make mayonnaise I've never fertilized
eggs I won't survive the post-apocalypse
and then you like mix it up and it just
like turns to it's crazy it's like aioli
similar it's like watching anything
don't talk about food food let's eat it
oil egg lemon juice or something like
that simple
all right
let's grab some super chats Conor
O'Brien says elon's just trying to
convince us to trust him so we can jab a
computer into our central nervous system
love his current moves though it is
important to never trust uh not not to
say that is important when you're using
technology have no trust with it have a
trustless system where you don't have to
trust or not trust it's built in where
it's all transparent there's no one
person he only consumes the center
rejects both sides and substitute a
healthy metal that's right trustless I
told you I trusted you a couple days ago
and I don't normally say that to people
I appreciate that man you opened up too
shame you know the times of India is
talking about India's giving personhood
status to elephants have you guys heard
this it's about time yeah yeah well
that's not what elephants yes yeah we
have to change the definition yeah
change it yeah
James moaning says is Elon playing both
sides in order to further humanity and
Technology appease China tried to keep
America together since they are big
powers and shame is big fan of Freedom
Tunes got my dad to Laugh To The World
War II soldiers coming to the future
episode I am so glad thank you I'm glad
you enjoyed that can I actually give an
answer to the Elon question
so again I've mentioned I'm somewhat
skeptical I do consider myself possib
you know uh I consider myself cautiously
optimistic I will say this there is a
question that is asked by many left
Wingers is it the case that the
corporations that forward our causes
actually care about left-wing causes or
are they just obeying us because they're
scared and the answer to that question
is kinda doesn't matter
they're still forwarding their causes
and they won't forward their causes when
it's not popular for them but
I would say the fact that Elon wants to
make Twitter a space which is more open
and friendly to conservative thought is
a very good thing even if he isn't
necessarily doing it for the right
reasons though as I said cautiously
optimistic caution is the key word all
right W Falcon says speaking of
Starships what is the story behind the
spinning UFO and what it has to do with
your email also like the Mexican flag
behind shim it also excuse me excuse me
what
it All Began on One Summer Night well I
actually things spun the UFO I actually
have the uh the story it's kind of a
crazy story actually a lot of people um
might be CR might be surprised to hear
how this uh UFO thing came to happen so
uh I was taking a dump one day and I was
scrolling through Instagram and as I was
scrolling through Instagram I got an ad
for a floating UFO lamp and I clicked
buy now and it auto filled and then I
forgot about it and then a couple weeks
later a UFO appeared and I was like oh
yeah that thing well and then we had a
keyboard cleaner and I was like oh I bet
I could spin it sure now what's hold on
what's especially creepy is that Tim was
muttering to himself on the toilet about
how bad he wanted a UFO spinning lamp
and then immediately the ad came up on
Instagram I heard him talking about the
space slingshot yep yep I I just
Instagram advertised one day Instagram
started advertising electric bikes to me
and then I was just like okay buy some
electric bikes deadly you're giving them
what they want it's working do you
remember what brand this is by the way
people ask from time to time I don't
know is it just a magnet it's a
Bluetooth speaker it's not like
electromagnet yeah so it's floating
magnetically and then it's a Bluetooth
speaker which we never we haven't really
utilized we gotta turn that on I didn't
realize that you took the flag of my
people down from behind oh I'm sorry I
did that yeah I'm sorry
sir Timothy cast your show Sheamus the
guest last night wasn't as Irish as you
are so I had to swap the flags out
that's so they needed it more oh yeah
you're right I'm sorry I didn't think
about that all right let's read some
more Lori MC says it's 8 40 p.m timcast
IRL is not showing up via the YouTube
search what's going on you know what's
going on so head over to timcast.com to
become a member because
um you know I I I I regret not setting
up the website sooner but you can only
learn when you learn and we set it up
over a year ago and we should have done
it in 2020 because it was an election
year but uh we are we are building up
our fortification so in the event we get
booted from YouTube or whatever the
company still exists the show still
exists we're on multiple platforms we
actually get tons of views on other
platforms so I think we're good I think
we are good we're we're going to be
implementing a lot more infrastructure
changes moving forward we're starting
with this one I can't wait till we get
our TV app because then you're going to
be able to go on your TV download the
app and then it's going to have a bunch
of shows now of course the app stores
have their rules too so we're doing what
we can with what we can but I want to
point out Adam Crigler because people in
the chat are pointing out Adam Crigler
may have been the inventor of the let's
spin the UFO I'm not sure was he the
first one to spin the UFO he may he may
have been uh Adam Crigler you watched
psychonaut I think what happened was I I
posted on Instagram spinning the UFO
with the the the the blower thing and
then I think Adam decided to make it a
show oh it's such a good element but I
could be wrong it may have been Adam
yeah
he was the man who spun the UFO it was
not me he was the UFO spinner and he
actually he has the original UFO he does
this is this is not spins it yep ours is
a humble knockoff Adam's been very cool
to me gave me free shoes when he was
moving he didn't have enough shoes or he
had too many shoes to take with him he's
like do you on some I was like I guess I
could use some shoes
which I would highly recom he said I
said can I have some of your coffee no
no
absolutely not heard it screaming I was
like all right dude I'm sorry that's not
what he said he said yeah for money I
was like I don't have that I'm a
cartoonist
all right let's see we got David the
senior says Ian the earthquake Tesla
caused was because he hooked up a Tesla
coil to a power supply and cycled the
output back into the coil he stopped it
by Smashing it with a sledgehammer whoa
Is that real what a great story I love
that guy don't you hate when that
happens super chatter and Nicola we
accidentally make an earthquake that's
so rough so many super chances
Omega says when they say no uterus no
say I say no gun no control my point to
them is I keep my hands off your uterus
as you keep yours off my guns very
libertarian approach but I don't think
that answers the conservative
um perspective yeah I mean like people
have uh people have a responsibility to
behave in ways that don't harm other
human beings and even if you don't have
the specific body part that they need to
be responsible with does not mean you
can't comment on it it's such a
ridiculous I was talking to my brother
and he was mentioning how some people
were like
uh abortions need to be legal because
what if I'm in a bad relationship I need
to get out of it and it's like that's
actually the argument's put forward by a
lot of people especially liberals and
it's kind of a crazy thought it's like
you're in a bad relationship quick kill
my son yeah I don't understand that
argument makes zero sense well there's
the threat that she would leave you and
take the kid and then you have to pay
money to her for the rest of your life
imagine having a five-year-old kid and
being like son I ran out of money
that's right
that's right I ran out of money quick
kill the kids no no no no no no all
right all right Mega Samer Ernie says
about the radioactive Boy Scout he
didn't try to build the death ray he
tried to build his own nuclear reactor
as a Boy Scout he succeeded to a point
really interesting story you can hear on
YouTube what badge was that for is that
why he's called radioactive Boy Scout
yeah oh my goodness is he a nuclear
reactor badge yeah you got to build the
nuclear reactor that can power your
house uh you'll get your badge dude we
were just like we were just like making
fire that's wild
Texas best mobile notary says you need
to invite Kirk Cameron he runs save the
storks an organization whose purpose is
to support pregnant moms considering
abortion you have to see their mobile
facility
didn't he do this really awful uh banana
argument
I don't know he's like
um he argued that the banana was like
evidence of God because it's perfect
it's easy to say when he's not here Tim
it is I remember watching this video so
if you can correct me if I'm wrong but I
think I might have seen that he was
mentioning how the bananas its own
rapper it's biodegradable pretty cool
the food is inside it it fits our hand
perfectly and everyone's response is
like yo we cultivated the banana like
over thousands of years the actual wild
bananas are starchy and hard to eat yeah
it's not necessarily yeah the banana
arguments remember Ray comfort and Kirk
Cameron
and then there was another video another
thing where he was arguing against
Evolution and he showed a picture of
like a duck with an alligator head or
something see if you can look that up
it's been a long time he did a good
series of movies but he said uh Cameron
right well Growing Pains was one of the
best shows but I I think the argument
was If evolution was real where is the
species of species cross and he showed
like a duck a duck alligator head Kirk
Cameron something like that I could be
wrong it's been like 20 years I just
think there's a much stronger
it's got its own Wikipedia so here's my
point the Platinum us that's where it is
well also are things venomous it
secretes are they venomous yes I thought
they were cute no they're venomously
wait hold on how does cute preclude
venomous that's right
you can't hurt people there's an action
anymore
and I think you have to be dangerous to
truly be cute right thank you the Croco
duck was an argument yeah yeah I think
so let's see the crocodile fictitious
animals that are dangerous by 2007 by
Earth Earth creationists this is what
they call them but whatever Ray comfort
and Kirk Cameron uh same guys so I think
like the existence of the universe in
general is a much stronger argument for
God than bananas specifically I have to
agree yeah I thought it was a terrible
like why is there everything instead of
nothing it's a really big question look
at this banana it's proof of God I'm
like I mean not in the way you think
like the existence of life and the
universe perhaps but the fact the band
fits in your hand it's like it's like
Peter Griffin watching the plastic bag
circling in the wind and God's like what
are you looking at look at all this cool
stuff over here and he's like this is
amazing whatever all right what do we
got here DD says timcast you guys always
talk about factory farms I suggest you
have someone on from one I live on a
dairy farm that many people call the
factory farm and it's a business that is
so misunderstood if you need someone I
can send some your way to hear their
perspective I got a better idea why
don't we send documentary filmmakers to
go to misrepresented spaces and oh yeah
film them
you want to do it no well no I've got
some well I guess misrepresentative if
you're talking about like Bali or like
under the under the water off the coast
of Indonesia I'm down to go rectify the
perception of that area I think we
should send people to what would you do
everywhere everywhere Luke Rutkowski
went to Somalia and I think he did a
really great video on what it was it was
like very honest it was like there's
crime but it's it's also not so bad in
certain areas and you know there's a lot
of like I think it was great when he
went there and he just made videos about
it I want to do documentaries with
Lauren Southern off the coast literally
off the coast of Indonesia there's all
these temples under the water since the
last flood and she was like yo we should
do it it's fascinating yeah that'd be
really fun cool yeah that'd be super
cool yeah dude you'd be perfect for that
yeah what's it called the Bimini Road I
think is that there I'm gonna look that
up now that you can fly without a mask
on the the world is your oyster yes I'm
gonna go to uh
we're gonna be Shameless Sheamus over
here we did a freedom Tunes cartoon
about the masks being lifted y'all need
to check it out fans really loved it I
think you guys will love it I was uh I
was sending Sheamus a message and I used
voice to text and I said something like
hey Sheamus we need to record the
voiceover for the chicken thing and then
it said Sheamus we need to record the
voiceover and then when I clicked finish
Sheamus turned into Shameless like if
that isn't big Tech trying to malign me
I don't know what it is but it was weird
because it like it got Seamus right but
then turned it into Shameless like you
know when you're doing voice attack
voice attacks at real time translates
yeah so you know what happened at the
beginning of the sentence it was like he
could be talking about any Sheamus but
then by the time he got to the end it
knew it was me and so it had to change
it yeah I got a correction on the Bimini
Road it's it's off the coast of uh the
Bahamas and it's this underwater like
rectangular sub-rectangular Limestone
blocks that stretched for 0.8 kilometers
and you need to remove yourself from
this documentary immediately
super chats Richard Knight says quote if
the civil war was the price the United
States paid for slavery then God help us
when it comes to paying the price for a
legalized abortion and Coulter I'm
concerned with factory farming what
God's going to do to us for that so good
you know what I was thinking
um
can you uh name points in history in
which people were stripped of their
personhood
where where like uh in American history
specifically since this Inception of
this country
um I'm not saying that there isn't one
I'm saying can you bring up an example
of when
something went to the courts and they
said this person no longer has any
constitutional rights
that's a really good question so I think
an argument that would be made would be
just slavery in general
um no so when you're talking about
you're saying like the court actually
saying you're not a person see uh so a
personhood was revoked is what right
like someone had it and it was taken
away and a mass like a Supreme Court
ruling the reason I pushed back on the
on the slavery thing is that actually
slavery existed before the Inception of
this country and then it started with
this country and then eventually the
courts ruled to Grant personhood has
there been a circumstance where they're
like this group of people hereby is
revoked of their constitutional rights
in the U.S I don't know I don't think so
criminal I'm not saying it's not true I
think I'm wondering I think you could
always do process also I think you could
argue that the Three-Fifths Compromise
was a revoking of personhood
because they actually ruled that this is
not a full person well that's
interesting because the South argued
slaves had full percentage for voting
but not other rights so they didn't
actually have persons really yeah it was
the north that wanted them to have no
rights the north argued that slaves
without personhood should not be granted
the right to vote in the south of course
this makes sense The South was like we
want more votes
we have people here and they're a lot in
the north was like no you can't have
slaves and then say they can vote as
well because then the slave owner is
telling them who to vote for yeah
yeah it it makes no sense the South
would take away their own votes
so the issue is I don't think the slaves
ever had personhood it was only that
they were granted some more the reason I
bring this up is because I was thinking
about the abortion argument and I
wondered what's the right side of
History well unborn babies be granted
personhood or be denied their personhood
and here's what I ultimately came up
with and again could be wrong I'm not a
historian Plessy versus Ferguson was an
instance where they were like Hey we're
not going to enshrine Absolute rights
because you know it's basically like
separate but equal but eventually that
gets done away with so there was a
ruling where it was like we will
enshrine the existing infrastructure
but eventually it gets dissolved I
wonder then if the only possible outcome
in the in the abortion argument is that
personhood will be granted to unborn
babies and I'll layer one on top of that
India is going to Grant elephants
personhood if we are but it's it's kind
of funny but if we as a civilization as
a species are coming to the point where
we're recognizing the personhood of
animals than certainly unborn humans
will will likely be granted when they
start neural netting babies in the womb
and the mom wants to communicate with
the kid when it's four months developing
and they're gonna have like mind melds
with it then for sure they'll have
personhood and the the program will
default that all babies have Patrick
Stewart's voice
very good show number one are you coming
make it so mother I enjoy it when you
eat fudgicles I am craving pickles and
peanut butter right now mother I I have
to admit I am ripping off a Family Guy
joke yes they have the little little
baby girl or is that American oh yeah
that is baby girls boys by Patrick
Stewart but to your point I would say
that they did almost revoke personhood
in a way like if you go go back and look
at tort law as it refers to The Unborn
and then all of a sudden row passes and
you know abortions that's interesting
that they did I did pull up that Amicus
brief that said in 1850 to 1880s they
viewed The Unborn
so it's I'm just I wonder I don't know I
don't know for sure let's read a couple
more Super chats
all right let's see
free men Die free says legal abortion is
state-sanctioned murder the government
giving women authority to be the
Arbiters of life or death it's a mockery
of the classical liberal idea of
equality and equality under the law
there are interesting arguments about
the right of the government to mandate a
woman provide her body to another being
though I understand the arguments about
responsibility
and then it becomes
it's completely unique I was talking to
somebody earlier about this
if you invite someone in your home and
say you can live here you can't kick
them out like after a certain amount of
time there's like you can't just kick
them out yeah if someone sneaks into
your house and sleeps there for a
certain amount of time you can't legally
kick them squatters rights yup yeah but
that's not what everywhere is it though
uh I think probably most places I could
be wrong if someone kicks your door in
and comes in your house says I'm living
here now you call the police they'll
remove that person
now that's not a good A Perfect Analogy
for you know a baby in a womb but I
understand the argument that if a woman
invites a life into her womb you can't
then be like I'm gonna kill it yeah well
I mean the problem is none of the
analogies really work because ultimately
we're looking at the relationship
between a parent and a child and parents
do owe children the means to support
them not even that we're looking at
something that is unique there's there's
there's there's no circumstance in which
someone runs up to you and then bites
you and then their veins go into your
veins and I was like oh no now I'm
attached by Blood what do I do that
doesn't happen like well and even that
wouldn't be right analogy right because
the child is not the initiator the child
exists because of you
right so there's a question about the
right to evict in the instance of rape
where the woman did not choose to allow
someone to use her body and but then why
it's not the woman's fault the state is
going to mandate she has to give her
body to somebody else yeah I I would
never allow the government to say I had
to give my blood to somebody by force
never gonna happen that's different I'm
looking up squatters rights and pretty
Most states are 10 years or more there's
there's six states where it's seven
years or less Arkansas California
Florida Tennessee and Utah but you're
looking at something I think that's kind
of different this is from Anders if
someone like is living in a house for 30
days they can make a legal argument and
not be a victim so there's an issue of
whether or not they gain rights over the
property to own under squatters rights
other or are they tenants is it it's how
long you've known that they're in the
house or how long they've been in the
house because if the mom doesn't know
she's pregnant till 20 or 30 days like
what's Plan B that that birth control
when it actually it causes a fertilized
egg to get passed out of the body like
is that murder no I believe Plan B stops
the fertilism station that's debated
it's debated I'm just saying dude if I
was responsible in every single way and
someone forced something into me and
then the state said and now you have to
provide your body to it I'd be like no I
don't think that's an app analogy so for
example you cannot be forced to just
provide food to a random stranger right
but if you have a baby you can't just
stop feeding them and allow them to
starve to death because that's your time
that's a different relationship talking
about we're talking about someone child
that's in the womb forcefully putting
something into your body to consume your
blood yeah but I don't think that's an
analogy that can really I don't think
that that works as an analogy to
pregnancy bro I got to tell you man I I
don't know if it matters what you think
in terms of the analogy what matters is
women would kill themselves before
allowing the state to do that that's
actually one of the issues we have like
I understand the argument about elective
abortion for no reason
but there is a serious problem when a
woman gets raped and then the state says
and now you have no choice and then they
slip their throats I don't I mean do you
have any statistics to verify that that
is An Occurrence to the places where
abortion is illegal and I understand
what you're saying but it's not an
argument no you're saying that if we
don't allow people to kill their babies
they're going to Slit their throats I'm
saying I I understand absolutely people
who if they were forced to have another
life form attached to their body and
they did everything responsibly abided
by the law and someone else pins them
down and puts a baby in them and they
say I did not choose this and I will not
give my body I was responsible and the
state says you have no choice there are
if it was me I'd be like either no the
state has no right to force this
position on me because of because of Mer
because this crazy person did this to me
or I'd probably just say off with it
yeah
extreme example though because it's such
a small percentage of abortions that I
feel like it's it's exaggerated to be
this well you know what are you going to
do if they're raped to to mask all of
these other abortions for no reason I
completely agree elective abortion I
think is people just being like up time
for birth control but that but I'm
saying there isn't there is a there is
an issue there and how you deal with it
and if people look maybe it's one in a
million well I'm just saying I'm I am
I'm the kind of person that will not
tolerate the state coming to me and
stripping me of my right we're on the
verge of never but you don't have a
right to kill a baby so you're not being
stripped of your right no no if if
somebody commits a crime against me yeah
and puts me in a negative position and
then the state seeks to impose something
on me because I was victimized you ain't
playing that game but then what are your
limitations on that do you have no no no
no they can they can give the baby
everything it needs to live but it's not
getting my blood what are your trimester
limitations on that then like you know
do they have to get it taken care of
right away can they think about it for a
minute after the first trimester I say
my personal opinion is no like but is it
not an imposition of the third trimester
you're giving it your blood it isn't in
position but this it's called compromise
it's called like if someone kicks your
door and lives in your house for 30 days
the government's like well you could
have kicked him but what if what if
they're raped and they don't know
they're pregnant until second or third
trimester that is a very serious
challenge it is and there's a problem of
if you want to make the argument that
someone made a choice to have a baby in
them
if you want to make the argument that
the baby should not be killed agreed but
if you want to make the argument that a
person who was forced into a position by
a criminal now has to provide their body
to someone else I'm not I won't do it
that's someone else is their child
doesn't matter
people should have to provide for their
children if someone victimizes me that
would be horrible and the state tries to
victimize me further trust me that game
will not be played by me you're not
optimized by not being able to kill
yourself but I don't know that I mean
that's assuming that having a child is
you know traumatizing or victimizing I
mean for somebody who like I'm look I I
think you guys are are
not being you know like I don't think
you're listening to the what I'm saying
I hear what you're saying I think you're
making it about a matter of personal
choice what I'm saying is you can't kill
babies you have the circumstances are
really difficult I think it's a tragedy
when a woman's raped I think it's
unbelievably horrific and I think but I
think abortion is also a crime against
women as well I don't think it heals
them I think they have to carry around
the burden of the fact that their child
is now dead I don't think it's a good
thing for the victim either and
ultimately you are killing a child that
just can't be justified I don't I don't
fault the baby I think
um we need to develop develop better
Technologies for saving the life of the
unborn child but I also think the state
saying your blood your body to someone
else is is a line too far but it's your
child but where does it stop though I
mean you could go into reproductive
coercion you could say oh you know maybe
I was in this relationship and I didn't
really want to have a I mean where is
this it stops when you're like if it's
only forcible violent rape from someone
you don't know because rape still
happens with people you know or yeah
the issue is if we're talking about
someone being personally responsible I
do not agree the state has a right to um
impose
responsibility on you in terms of your
bodily autonomy
I don't think the the like let's say you
have a son right and that son has a
kidney problem I don't think the state
can be like you need to give your kidney
to this kid but your kidney does not
exist for you to give it to your child
the uterus literally exists for a child
to grow in it but that's the purpose of
the organ the organs being used properly
stop a rapist it's a question of
personal responsibility if a person does
everything and they're personally
responsible then it's unfortunate but
you can't force someone to give up but
they do so when you if you were if
you're raped and you go to the hospital
they will give you emergency
contraceptives great well so hold on but
I think I think you're conflating fault
and responsibility right that if someone
is raped it's not their fault that
they're pregnant it's still their
responsibility to not kill their child
though
I just think I I look I I get it I
completely get it but for someone like
me I'll tell you right now I would not
allow it to happen if you are right if
you go to the police and they take you
to the hospital you're given plan b or
an emergency contraceptive and I'm glad
that we're doing things like that and
I'm glad that we have restrictions I
think the left position is psychotic
but I think there's there's there's
there's there's got to be personal
um Liberties but if that solution exists
and plan B you can take up to I believe
it's 72 hours if that solution exists
why allow abortion
because there is a solution that's not
abortion well but that's debatable
there's an argument to me that plan B is
actually an abortifacient let's read one
more Super Chat and because I don't like
people are saying but we'll talk more
about this stuff with the Pfizer data 2
and the members in the members segment
all right uh let's see we'll read one
more here
what is that dorktanian the state isn't
victimizing you it's preventing you from
victimizing innocent life aside rap is
such a small percentage of abortion rape
such a small percentage of abortions
it's disingenuous to make a policy off
of it I don't disagree with that that's
why I mostly disagree with abortion but
you know we've I think we've talked
about it to a bit Ad nauseam so instead
of just dragging on let's do the member
segment
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we're going to talk about Pfizer's data
and um I don't think YouTube would allow
it I don't know for sure maybe they
would but it's just crazy stuff so we'll
have it over at timcast.com you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast Ashley you want to
shout anything out up thepost
millennial.com check it out we're gonna
have a lot of really cool stuff coming
up you have Twitter account I do at
Sinclair Ashley follow me on there if
you're brave
right on I've got a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we make cartoons
and animations I think you guys will
really enjoy them we just uploaded one
this week about Elon Musk getting his
clutches on Twitter and how the left is
reacting and I think you guys will enjoy
it so go check it out love you I'm
getting the vibe that a lot of YouTube
admins tonight really wanted us to talk
about the the Pfizer dump so sorry I
know we're treading lightly I would love
to get get more raw let's do it let's do
it in the future but we need we need to
know that it's gonna be okay beforehand
because Tim is Tim is cautious in these
regards and that is why he's successful
in many ways also bear Kennedy in the
comments yesterday said that every time
I rolled a hundred-sided die he checks
the wild magic surge table in Dungeons
and Dragons when you're a wild Mage
sometimes things go wrong when you're
trying to cast spells and some random
thing happens so I'm gonna do that for
you tonight bear Kennedy with the idea
what happens is you roll 100 side I got
a 22. then you go to your wild magic and
something crazy happens when you get a
22. for the next day you have advantage
on the next two D6 rolls you make where
you don't already we have advantage that
means he wins all the arguments that's
very good for me I mean if I didn't
succeed first I get to try again for
free great for the next 24 hours and
we'll do it on the after show awesome
I'm looking forward to that I was gonna
say too that we don't talk about on
YouTube so that we can continue to talk
to you guys here although I'm very
excited to get over onto Rumble
hopefully maybe someday we could live
stream from Rumble in the future we'll
see what shakes out very excited for
that Branch
um you guys can follow me on Twitter and
minds.com at sour patchlets as well as
sour patchlets.me we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys